i gave it back
hi good morning be seated ladies and
gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen i do apologize for
the delay this morning we were ready to
go uh shortly after nine o'clock
i was on the bench and we were ready to
proceed but there was a a legal issue
that came up that involved not the next
witness but the following is one of the
expert witnesses so i wanted to resolve
that with counsel before we heard from
the witness so we didn't have to do it
either at sidebar or excuse you during
the doctor's testimony so i think we
have it resolved and hopefully things
will proceed smoothly
we're going to hear from another late
witness first council call your next
witness please
the defense calls boyd martin
uh please place your left hand on the
bible sir raise your right hand and
listen to my court clerk who will
administer an oath
do you swing the presence of almighty
god that the testimony against this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your name us
by your last name for the record uh boyd
martin uh m-i-r-t-i-n thank you all
right mr martin have a seat please keep
your voice up nice and loud
if you don't understand a question
please indicate that to the court and
i'll have council rephrase go ahead
council good morning uh mr martin
um
where do you live i live in cochranville
pennsylvania
are you a uss i am
uh
what do you do for a living uh i my wife
and myself train uh horses my wife's a
dressage rider i'm a three-day event
rider uh in our sports three-day
eventing uh has dressage show jumping
and cross-country it's an olympic sport
is um philip dutton uh also in that
sport yes he is okay
um
and do you compete nationally in the
united states yes uh and uh actually
internationally representing america
uh and in what competitions have you
represented america in international
competitions
um
i've gone to three olympic games i think
four um world equestrian games and i
think two pan-american games
um
do you know michael barrisson yes how
did you first come to know him uh
michael in the equestrian world is
a legend he's a very very well-known uh
famous dressage trainer
i met him i believe in
2010
um he's so good that
he started actually training and
coaching me
and helping me develop my riding in
dressage to a higher level
did he train you as well as your horse
yeah i mean he's a a remarkable guy he's
obviously uh one of the best riders
in this country or if not the world
uh and i sort of went to him for
improvement of my own riding and the
improvement of horses he's
brilliant horse trainer great mentor
coach competitor
also a guy that's been there and done it
that sort of helped help me in my career
and point me in the right direction
so approximately how many years of
experience do you have
observing michael barros from
interactive forces
uh well since being in this country
probably uh watching him for a couple of
years before i started training with him
but uh closely sort of in a 10-year
period
have you in that time period ever seen
michael barrasson abuse an animal
absolutely not michael uh
is a fantastic horseman uh to get the
the best out of the horses the thing i
learned with michael is sort of trust
and confidence and
you know he's a passionate trainer and
uh
you know really um
pointed me in the direction of sort of
working with the animal without force
did there come a time when your
relationship with michael evolved beyond
him being a coach and mentor into
something else yeah i mean i i'm
attracted to michael just because of uh
his character and his personality and i
think over time uh you know you start
off as coach and student and um
and then uh you you somewhat develop a
friendship
um
you know i love the guy he uh
he was fun to be around uh he was
a great teacher
we had the same um love for horses the
same sort of goals and drive for
competition
and um
yeah i'd have to say that we became good
friends
did he assist you at all in uh
an appearance at the london olympics in
2012.
yeah michael was was remarkable he uh
he actually flew to england and trained
and coached me at no cost
and he was instrumental on helping me
get to my first olympic games and
um
you know something i'll always remember
of how he sort of dropped everything
here in america and came to england and
and worked with me um
to prepare for the olympics were you at
the rio olympics in 2016. yes did
michael assist you in connection with
that competition yeah he was um coaching
some of the pure dressage uh riders of
that contest um but he definitely was an
influence to me at that point there i
mean when you go to the olympic games
you
you know there's long build up there's
weeks of where you're sort of in a
training camp and
yeah definitely michael was there and
an assistant
so did you develop a friendship with him
yes
uh did you ever socialize with them
outside of the context of horses
yes uh tell us about that
um like when you go to the
you know these championship events you
often you know training a horse takes
about an hour and uh you're there and uh
you hung out together you obviously had
dinner together um
my wife and myself owned a dressage
horse that we brought over from
australia
and
um we believed michael was so good at
improving horses we actually sent this
horse to his training facility in new
jersey and went up and watched michael
train the horse and
um enjoyed dinner with him afterwards
and
you know he was uh you see him at
competitions as well um
and uh he's a
i don't know like he's one of those
people you're drawn to at the show like
he's larger than life and
just fun to be around
based upon your
interactions with him professionally and
socially did you develop
any sort of impression as to
his
truthfulness as a person
yeah i mean he is a to me a very
honorable and truthful person i think to
achieve what he's achieved in his career
um you can't be a con like it's so hard
work it's such a long road
it's just thousands and thousands of
hours of training and practice
and you can't
you can't get to where michael's got to
in his career
by being a phony and i'd say he's a very
honorable character he's uh truthful
and all the dealings i had with him as a
coach and student and him training our
horses and seeing him socially
he was a very truthful person have you
ever co-owned horses with michael
uh we had this one horse called jeff the
chef that michael trained and improved
and we ended up selling the horse uh and
so we owned the horse but um
we um we believe we michael got a
commission on the sale
do you have a barn facility in
pennsylvania
yes we have a farm in cochranville
pennsylvania
was was there ever a time where there
was a a horrific fire at a facility you
were associated with
yeah unfortunately in
2011 i was actually renting a a
16 stall barn
um it was just
come to america in 2007 and
it was a tragic event it was um there
was an electrical fire that happened in
the middle of the night from an
electrical
product called a hay steamer
and it was a disaster
this machine was a faulty machine
and the
machine caught on fire the whole
building burnt down
i believe six horses died the whole
building was destroyed we managed to
save a number of the horses but it was a
yeah it was a horrible horrible event
as a horse owner
if you had been in that barn and noticed
that that hay steamer was somehow
malfunctioning would you have done
something to address it hold on hold on
let me see outside more
sustained
you mentioned that michael was
passionate in his work
could you elaborate on that for the jury
i mean to be uh to be an olympic athlete
as successful as michael you've got to
have determination and drive and
positivity positivity
uh you know he was larger than life uh a
passionate guy uh
i don't know how much more to explain it
but he he had a
flamboyant personality
he loved so much what he did um
it was really uh i was magnetized to it
a little bit like he when he's coaching
he could hear it in his voice or
you know there was times where he'd
wake up at three in the morning up here
in new jersey and drive to our farm and
be there before i even woke up to train
us and
you know he he just loved horses
he loved seeing us succeed
and he's he was just passionate about um
his coaching and everything he did
throughout your association with michael
barrisson did you ever witness him
mistreating another person
never no i mean there's
coaching any athlete i think
you know in sports there's times where
your voice would get elevated or you
might use a curse word but um
you know i think it was definitely in my
experiences is just because of how much
he wanted you to improve but that was
never abusive or anything like that
no further questions all right any
cross-examination
thank you judge uh mr martin you weren't
at mr barriston's farm on august 7 2019
and you're aware that he's on trial for
attempted murder yes
no questions judge thank you all right
you may step down sir thank you
i call your next witness defense calls
dr steven simmering
hi doctor left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand as my clerk will
swear you in do you swing the presence
of almighty god that the testimony gives
to this court regarding this matter
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth
i do please state your name and spell
your last name stephen
thank you please keep your voice up nice
and loud
go ahead direct examination
[Music]
good morning doctor good morning
where do you uh reside currently doctor
you reside in tana fly in new jersey
and uh
what do you do for a living i'm a
psychiatrist
and
um
can you give us a little bit of
background with regards to your
education yeah psychiatry is a specialty
of medicine
i went to college at columbia i went to
medical school at nyu i did my
general surgery residency at bellevue
hospital and then i did a psychiatric
residency at columbia presbyterian new
york state psychiatric institute
um
i after that i was in the u.s army
medical corps for three years what did
you do in the us army i treated
psychiatric patients who were military
usually vietnam
people coming back and forth from
vietnam
i returned then to new jersey i became
the medical director of mount carmel
guild community mental health center
which is part of catholic charities i
did that for about three years and then
i joined what was then called new jersey
medical school now known as rutgers and
for the next almost 30 years i was
director of medical student education at
new jersey medical school in newark
at times i was vice chair of the
department i ran the residency training
program but i was usually in charge of
medical student education
after that i returned to colombia where
i still am and i directed the forensic
or legal psychiatry training program at
columbia
throughout all this time i've been in
private practice of psychiatry where
i've seen
individual patients with therapy and
i've also done forensic or legal
evaluations
and approximately
how many patients have you seen and
evaluated over your career i've seen
thousands of cases
and uh how long have you been
in psychiatry well i i finished my
residency in psychiatry in 1970
then i went to the army and then in 1973
i received board certification so i'm a
board-certified psychiatrist can you
explain to the ladies and gentlemen the
jury what board certified
well psychiatry is a specialty of
medicine like surgery or radiology in
order to do that you need to graduate
from medical school and finish an
approved residency
after that there's an examination to
measure your qualification
and i passed that examination in 1973 it
became board certified oddly enough it's
lifetime certification nowadays people
have to do it every 10 years to take
recertification however i didn't get
away with it because in 2014
uh or no 1994
they developed a sub specialty in
forensic or legal psychiatry and i
passed that board and that board is
renewable every 10 years so board
certification means that after
completing all the requirements and
established board of experts will
evaluate your your uh capability and
competency
now do you have any uh or have you been
appointed to any
university in the board
well yes i mean when i was at new jersey
medical school i sat on many many of the
committees uh i was there for many many
years and my work mainly involved
students
at columbia the same thing i was
involved with residents and the training
of residents as part of my columbia job
i also train
residents at cornell cornell has a
partnership with colombia through new
york presbyterian hospital so i spent
much of my life in academic medicine and
at the same time i've seen private
patients throughout this whole time
did you have any hospital appointments
yes i have a hospital well for many
years i was hospital appointed to
university hospital
in newark which is part of umdnj or new
jersey med school again now called
rutgers they keep changing the names
since 2005 when i returned to colombia i
received an appointment at columbia
presbyterian hospital known as new york
presbyterian columbia and then i
received an appointment at new york
presbyterian wild cornell that's the
east side hospital they have a
partnership in new york presbyterian
hospital so i have two hospital
appointments
have you received any uh awards or
honors with regards to your work in
psychiatry most of the awards i received
over the years have been teaching awards
how about any committee assignments
well that's part of academia as you
serve on committees everybody serves the
committee so you don't get much credit
for it but part of the duties in
academia is serving on committees
do you have any specific
research interests that you've
pursued medical student education
now
have you written any article
i've written a few not that many over
the years they're listed in my cd
uh any books authored any book yeah i've
written a few books uh they're more in
in the field of popular psychiatry more
than uh academic psychiatry for example
i co-authored the book
uh
making marriage work for dummies of all
things it's part of the dummy series
i wrote the compatibility quotient
co-authored that this has to do with
marriage i wrote a book with now the
current dean of new jersey medical
school robert johnson a book called the
race trap this really has to do back 20
years ago about black white race
relations he's african-american so we
had it from the point of view of a black
and a white doctor uh we're going to
revise that book because race relations
are so totally changed in the united
states i've written a few other books
dr you ever been qualified as an expert
in a court of law i have many times
and when you say many times
approximately how many times probably
hundreds of times most of the time i've
been qualified in the state of new
jersey i should have mentioned i'm
licensed in new jersey and new york i
have an inactive license in california
so that in new jersey in new york i
practice mainly in new jersey
occasionally in new york and of course
my appointment at columbia and cornell
is in new york um
so uh
i'm sorry i forgot your question
i think you answered it let me ask
another one thank you have you ever uh
testified as an expert on behalf of the
state oh yeah the prosecutor thank you i
was telling you about testifying most of
my testimony has been in superior court
in the state of new jersey i've
occasionally testified in supreme court
in new york which is the equivalent of
superior court
they have a
nutty kind of way of naming courts there
so their supreme court is like our
superior court i've testified in federal
court mainly in the state of new jersey
occasionally in new york that's called
the u.s district court
i've testified at arbitration hearings
as well i've testified occasionally out
of state
in psychiatry
and i've been qualified so i've been
retained
often by
in i do civil and criminal cases in
criminal cases i've been retained by
defense lawyers like you by the
prosecutor i've worked for mr shelton's
office and i've worked for many of the
prosecutors offices in the state of new
jersey i've been retained or appointed
by judges to do specific tasks
so i've been retained by people from
lawyers and judges from all sides
and you indicated that
you've been retained by the morris
county prosecutor's office in the past
oh i have yes
on one or more occasions
on
you know comes and goes i i've testified
in most of the counties in the state
i've been retained by many of the
prosecutors offices public defenders
offices and private attorneys
in morris county i did a lot of cases
when michael murphy was the county
prosecutor at that time
here in mars
here in mars uh and uh judge
michael murphy was the prosecutor at
that time after him i started doing
fewer cases here more cases in bergen
and essex but over the years i've done
mars county cases
now
judge at this point i'll move dr
simmering as an expert in psychiatry
forensic psychiatry right
yes
any objection or do you have any
questions for the doctor solely related
to his qualifications as an expert no
judge thank you all right very good uh
dr simmering
will be qualified by the court as an
expert pursuant to rule 702
based on his uh training his knowledge
his education skill and experience he
has been qualified before and he'll be
qualified this time as an expert in the
area of forensic psychiatry and he'll be
allowed to render his opinion
thank you
welcome doctor go ahead mr blencus can
you explain to the jury what forensic
psychiatry is
well forensic psychiatry is a
sub-specialty of psychiatry just as
psychiatry is a sub-specialty of
medicine it's a discipline and i i have
been qualified as an expert in
psychiatry with a sub-specialty in
forensic psychiatry forensic
psychiatrist the application of the
specialty of psychiatry to specifically
to legal issues
and legal issues come in a lot of
varieties many of them are civil cases
where one person is suing another and
brings up a
psychiatric issue a simple example of
that may be a will contest where the
state of mind of the test stated
willmaker is brought into
the question
some of these cases have to do with
claims of damages medical malpractice
sexual harassment or things like that
then there are criminal cases such as
this one and in a criminal case uh i
will render opinions as to an
individual's state of mind an
individual's dangerousness from a
psychiatric point of view an
individual's competency or fitness to
stand trial
a uh
and other factors dealing with an
individual state of mind as it applies
to the criminal charges and as i've
testified i've been retained by defense
prosecution and the court to render
these opinions
what's the difference between a
psychiatrist and a psychologist
the training is very different for the
purpose of testifying psychologists can
do very much what i do in telling the
jury
giving the jury expert opinions about
a person's state of mind however the
training is very very different
psychiatry is a specialty of medicine
you can't go into psychiatry unless you
go to medical school you know the old
joke was the psychiatrist is a doctor
who doesn't like to see blood
and you know that's a little bit funny
but it is a specialty as a
surgery internal medicine gynecology any
other specialty
psychology is an academic uh study uh
and instead of getting an md degree in
specializing as you do in psychiatry
you will aim toward a phd degree or a
psyd degree and you get an academic
degree and then you take courses and
then you become a specialist in
psychiatric issues so there although the
training is very different they often
converge in two places one place is
psychiatrists and psychologists
both often provide therapy so both can
be qualified to be psychiatric
therapists
second thing is both psychiatrists and
psychologists can do evaluations
i think the one place in which
psychiatry has an advantage in doing
evaluations is
questions of medication where medication
is concerned because part of my training
is training in the use and prescription
of medications
the one place where psychology has an
advantage is in testing pen and paper
psychological testing where they have an
advantage
doctor were you uh retained to evaluate
michael barrisson's
state of mind at the time of this
incident i was i was asked to see mr
barrisson
shortly
after really within a month of the
incident which occurred in early august
2019. now is there any significance as
to
when you see a particular individual
as far as the closeness to the event
with regards to rendering an opinion
well ideally you want to do an
evaluation as close to the event as
possible because it's fresh and
everything is fresh
the ideal circumstance is getting a call
from an attorney to see his client in
jail
or really in some kind of custody
or in the office
it would be great to see somebody
shortly afterwards that often doesn't
happen very often because of the way the
court system works i'm asked to see
somebody months or even years after an
event and then i have to reconstruct
what had happened that's certainly
possible but it makes it more difficult
here in this case i was asked to see mr
barriston the first time on september 6
2019 which is just a tiny bit more than
a month after the incident
okay and uh
again uh on that day you met with
michael barrisson correct i did
and that was in person yes it was that
was just before the past well it was
just before the pandemic yes
and
after the pandemic did you have an
occasion to meet with him on other
occasions i met with mr barrison four
more times uh throughout the year 2020
uh all of which were done by zuma
by that time much of my evaluations were
being done by zoom like most other
mental health professionals right did
you interview anyone else other than
michael barrison to
formulate your opinion in this matter
yes i had phone telephone interviews i
first i read all the records
statements paid by many many people
including michael barrasson's girlfriend
mary haskins clark
i've read statements by the victim in
this case her boyfriend people involved
in her life
i
spoke by phone specifically to two
people
one is stephen tarshis who is mr
barristones long-term lawyer and he was
involved in trying unsuccessfully
to put a stop to what was going on
between mr barrissone and um
uh andes canaric if i can stop you for a
second doc uh why did you contact
stephen tarshish as michael barisson's
attorney
this is a complicated case as i'm sure
the jury knows but one of the issues
was that as time went by
mr barrissone was trying everything
within his power to stop the
relationship between him and cataract
and goodwin in other words he wanted
them off his property and he wanted them
to leave they didn't want to leave
that's the simple part of it so he
wanted them to leave they were squatting
they didn't want to leave they claimed
they had a right to be there so mr
barrissone tried everything in his power
to get them to leave and among other
things he contacted the washington
township police on at least four
occasions and probably more than that
and asked for the help hold on a second
can i see council outside more please
testimony was not exactly responsive so
please ask another question
and i'm not sure we have to get into why
he spoke to someone because that
probably led the doctor to
testify as he did so
he certainly indicated who he spoke to
that's fine but
why he did it
information he received from those
people is not
something he should testify to now
we haven't all of a sudden in criminal
cases reduce the jury to seven jurors
i didn't think so i should have made
that clear at the outset thank you so we
have 16
including the first two rows thank you
didn't want to ignore the rest thank you
doctor i see that you're referring to
your report uh i'm just going to
give you a copy hold on mr blinkist
there's an issue with the court smart
recorder
all right we're good go ahead mr
balinkas
just so the record is clear i've marked
a copy of your report d 900
e-1 which i'll i'll place here
so if if you're referring to your report
which is not a problem
just indicate so and
that's the exhibit network that has been
marked thank you i have my own copy of
mr blankes
now
you indicated you spoke to
the attorney
did you speak to anyone else
with regards to michael barrison that
you used
and relied on as far as your evaluation
yes i spoke to his long-term
therapist
who has seen him in therapy for years
and
her
it's miss ricardo i'm looking at her
first name i'm blocking on that
i'm going to refer you to the first page
of your report second paragraph ask you
to review that oh here we go yeah thank
you
uh and picardo sorry i spoke to ann
picardo uh mr barristone had been seeing
ann picardo for therapy off and on for
many years so with mr barrisson's
permission i spoke to miss picardo to
gather her thoughts about his background
and did you receive information from
ricardo
that
you relied on with regards to the
formulation of your opinion i did and
can you tell the jury what information
she provided you
that you relied on as far as your
evaluation here
well i'm not sure how much detail you
want me to go into
whatever
detail
that you relied on and you believe it's
necessary to explain why you rendered
the opinion that you did okay
um
i can refer you to page 15.
thank you
sorry those are the past personal
history
what i learned from her
is that
he came from a
family which was emotionally and
physically abusive
that as a boy growing up
his mother according to her was very
selfish and very abusive to him his
mother by the way passed away in 2014
his father died in 2019 just after his
his arrest
miss piccardo remembered that in terms
of the history that uh one of the
maternal grandparents suffered from
depression and she believed that one of
the grandparents required shock
treatment electroconvulsive therapy and
why is that relevant
well depression runs in families and one
of my diagnoses uh
of my two diagnoses one of them is
persistent depressive disorder or
chronic depression
and so
that was relevant with regards to your
diagnosis regarding
the depressive
diagnosis that's correct
just one more piece of evidence people
with depression often have depressions
in the family some do not many do
right and what else if anything you rely
on she told me it is even more important
miss piccardo said that she had treated
mr barisson on and off for 20 years
uh never consistently but on and off
with depression and anxiety
and he would make appointments with her
and see her when he felt he needed care
she described him to me as this is a
direct quote very troubled
she thought he was at a considerable
risk for suicide and she believed that
even before the current events
he expressed to her after he spoke to
her after
the incident that he had lost everything
she also noted that throughout the years
in addition to being depressed he
appeared to be paranoid by which she
meant unduly suspicious of the motives
of others
and how is
that information relevant to your
diagnosis well my diagnosis is based on
my review of the records which are
extensive my review of the medical
records the incident reports
my five interviews with mr barristone
and also other information that comes
through such as medical records and
impressions from other treating
professionals all that helps me to
formulate a diagnosis
now
can you set forth
generally what you reviewed
that you relied on that forms your
opinion yes material is extensive as the
jury can see from this pile of papers on
my desk that's more than eight inches
thick
but uh just to summarize it i i had and
i'm reading now from my report where i
summarized everything
the legal documents uh washington
township investigation reports
which had to do with the current
incident
and um
visits that washington township made to
mr barrissone before the incident
dealing with difficulties he was having
with miss cataract and miss goodwin
did you review uh um the reports
with regards to michael barrasson's
9-1-1 calls to washington
i did there were several there were at
least four 9-1-1 calls in which sure in
the days before the shooting incident in
which mr barrison was increasingly uh
panicky and increasingly desperate to
get help for a situation which had been
spinning out of control and he put these
in the form of 9-1-1 calls officers
responded to the scene
but didn't do very much
and what
if any impact
did that have on michael barrasson's
state
can i see you for a minute
doctor with regards to the numerous
times that michael barrasson contacted
the washington police department and
called 911.
did you discuss with him
uh
his
feelings and beliefs
with regards to
those interactions with the police yes
not i did not discuss it with the police
i discussed the reports with mr barrison
and what did michael barrasson tell you
uh with regards to these numerous
attempts to try to uh get the town to
assist him mr barristone said he was
scared to death of lauren cataract and
he wanted help in any way he could get
it that he had tried everything he knew
calling his lawyer calling the police
trying to speak directly to lauren
canorack and her father jonathan
speaking to goodwin speaking through
intermediaries on the farm but nothing
worked and in the last several days
prior to the shooting itself he implored
the police for their help in putting an
end to the situation okay focusing
specifically just on his
contact with the police
what impact did that have on his mental
state
well mr barrison became increasingly
desperate because he saw himself in a
situation in which he was being
physically threatened
by lauren canorack and robert goodwin he
felt trapped he felt that there was no
way out despite the fact that he owned
the farm
that he had a reputation that he had
funds that he had education he felt that
he was um
unable to do anything to make this
situation go away and to get lauren
cataract to leave
now
in your interviews with michael barrison
did you have any
difficulty
communicating with him uh at any point
well yes the difficulty i had
communicating with him is he went into
incredible detail about everything and
it was very hard to pin him down to try
to get a trend of what he was thinking
he would answer the question and then he
would go off on showing me posts that
lauren counteracted on facebook with all
kinds of fantastic
threats
stories about
chess games
stories about other people and it was
hard to focus him on what his actual
thinking was because he was so
preoccupied with cataract and remained
preoccupied even after the shooting and
even after his arrest
and he was was he that same way in each
and every meeting that you had
he was now he was worse when i first saw
him i first saw him in
within a month a little more than a
month after the shooting i then saw him
four times in fairly
uh close uh proximity in april of 2020
so by that time a year uh
two years have passed
or i'm sorry a year had passed
and um
uh he had improved a little bit but he
remained focused and he remained
he wouldn't stop talking about what
happened and what lauren cataract was
doing and what she was still doing
he wouldn't stop writing he was
continuing to demonstrate to
produce documents saying all the things
that she did to him and all the things
he was afraid that she would do to him
it reached the point where i said to him
that i cannot process all this
information
would you please restrict it to a
hundred pages
i rarely have to do that with somebody
usually with examinees with patients i
want them to produce everything they can
but with him i said i cannot read
thousands of pages i want you to boil
this down and he finally did produce for
me a 91-page document with the high
points now
i show you what has been marked defense
exhibit 900
e-3
is this a copy of that
document you wish michael barrasson to
produce right this is the 91-page
document uh it wasn't numbered so uh at
when i reviewed this review mr blinkist
we numbered the pages for easy reference
i have my own copy okay now um
did you review and rely on what's
contained
in that document in formulating your
opinion
yes uh among other things i i don't
think i ever finished my last question
about the materials that i reviewed
and and i i started by saying i reviewed
the washington township police reports
both during the investigation of the
shooting itself and the four
visits the washington township police
made
to mr barrisson prior to the shootings
where he was imploring their help in
solving the situation
i reviewed investigation reports by the
morris county prosecutor's office i
reviewed reports by local police
i reviewed the indictment criminal
complaint the search warrant
i reviewed documents that had to do with
um
trying to obtain uh
mr barristone was convinced that bugs
had been placed listening devices had
been placed throughout the farm so he
retained a private firm called bug
sweeps to try to figure out where these
bugs were and what they were recording
i obtained uh medical records and this
had to do with the emergency room visit
the emergency squad that came out to the
farm after the shooting
and they took miss cataract to the
hospital they also took
mr uh
barrissone who had been injured himself
in the in the episode
i read the
notes from the emergency responders who
were first on the scene to gather their
impression of what things were happening
i read the doctor reports from mr
canorack and mr barrissone
then finally i read an extensive file of
correspondence text messages and social
media posts largely from lauren cataract
but others as well and the bulk of this
lengthy pile of documents that you have
here have to do with these posts
and text messages
was it brought to your attention that
there were over 19 000
pages of social media posts from lauren
cataract oh well yes that's why i told
mr barriston there is no way
you're going to get me to read 19 000
pages i have better things to do if you
want me to do this you're going to have
to boil this down to 100 pages and then
i'll read it that's pretty unusual
because normally in cases i kind of
scrounge for every scrap of relevant
material i could get but there was so
much of this stuff
now
was michael barristone
ever able in any of your meetings with
him
was he ever able
to
discuss the
specific
incident with you
well he talked about what happened up
until the time he jumped into his truck
and drove down to
the place where lauren cataract and
robert goodwin were residing he
remembered nothing about the incident
itself and then he talked about the
aftermath
so as far as the actual incident
he was never able to give you any
specific details
each and every time you talk to him that
is correct he gave me no details and he
gave law enforcement no details
now
you did realize that he is charged with
a criminal offense correct absolutely
and
did his
and i'm going to describe it as amnesia
with regards to that portion of the
event
cause you any concerns
and if so what did you do to address
those concerns well not at all he got
hit on the head which is probably the
most likely reason that he lost memory
uh during the confrontation
it happened very quickly and what
happened is not very clear but one of
the things seemed to be that robert
goodwin hit him on the head with his
cell phone and he suffered a hematoma
behind his ear and some other head
injuries that's the most likely reason
that he lost his memory however your
question has more to do with his current
fitness to stand trial does he remember
enough to stand trial and my answer to
that is absolutely because he can
provide the entire background he could
provide details of all the interactions
between him
counteract goodwin
and all the other relevant principles
and he can account for what happened
afterwards the fact that he got hit on
the head and don't remember the shooting
itself
does not undermine his ability to stand
trial and does not undermine my ability
to make a determination about what his
mental state was because there was
abundant evidence of his mental state
leading up to the actual shooting
now
with regards to his inability to recall
the specific events
uh you've indicated that
um the blows to his head
uh may very well be the
uh
the cause of that
probably i mean there's another
possibility when people are in periods
of high anxiety as he was he was
terrified when he jumped into the car as
far as i could tell he grabbed a pistol
he owned guns but he grabbed a pistol
it's kind of a ladies pistol a pink
pistol referred to as a lady's pistol
that belonged to his friend dr ruth cox
and he did it very impulsively jumped
into his car drove down there and
according to him he was afraid he'd be
killed and wanted to defend himself
now when people are in states of high
anxiety like that like any anybody can
remember like being say in a car
accident or being the victim of a crime
sometimes memory is not completely clear
for everything that happens because
anxiety is so high however i think the
most simple explanation is he got hit on
the head okay now
can you say definitively to a degree of
medical certainty
what the specific cause was either the
head injury or the
mental
state caused by anxiety well counselor
as you all know i can't say anything
definitively
i can offer an opinion to a reasonable
degree of medical probability which
means that it's highly likely medically
i can't testify as to anything at the
certainty also there are data missing
here about exactly what happened and and
i've read all the witness statements to
try to put it all together i think the
most likely explanation for his amnesia
is she got hit on the head and it's well
known and well documented that he got
hit on the head i read reports from
morristown memorial documenting all of
his injuries i think there is also the
possibility that his enormous
overwhelming state of anxiety may have
affected his memory that's the best i
can tell you okay now
did you review any documents
with regards to michael barrasson's
state of mind immediately after the
incident
that
you relied on
in helping you form that opinion that
you just testified well yes there were
many observers mainly the trained
observers from the emergency squad
emergency medical services and everybody
described the same thing
he was oriented to
person and and place in other words he
knew he was michael barrison and he knew
that he was on his farm so he knew that
however every observer commented that he
was confused about what had just
happened
every observer who saw him there must
have been a dozen observers on the scene
in the hospital emergency room in the
emergency bay at the hospital everybody
commented that he was confused about
what actually happened and actually to
this day
not to this day but to the last time i
saw him in april of 2020 he still did
not remember exactly what happened he
remembered what led to it he remembered
having the visitors from child
protective services he remember jumping
into his truck he remembered being
threatened and he remembered uh being
treated for injuries but did not
remember what happened in between now
that's different from knowing who he is
or where he is he did know who he is and
where he was
now
did you have discussions with michael
barrisson with regards to uh
various social media posts
i had extensive discussions with him
about media posts and the media posts
were almost all done by lauren canorack
some of them were old media posts where
she had posted
comments
about
other individuals often very negative
comments about other individuals i
discuss that with him if i can stop you
there doug i'm going to show you what
has been marked
d 900 e-4
which is a
social media post from uh a woman named
staggered
and captured
this is what we talked about this we're
not getting into the details why are you
showing it to them then
you're not getting into the details
which the court excluded why even show
it to him
doesn't that run the risk of an improper
comment
no because i i thought you told me i
could leave here
not as to the details that was part of
my ruling
any details judge
all right go ahead just be careful
doctor
i'm showing you 944
and 5
for the record their posts
from cataract to staggered
and from cataract to parkinson
do not say what's contained in here i've
seen these posts and did you discuss
these posts with michael barrasso i did
and
without
just discussing the content
how would you describe these posts
objection
you're asking this doctor's opinion on
it how did michael barrasson describe
exactly he's post to you without
referring to the content he found them
very scary
what effect did
those posts
based on your discussions with michael
barristan
have
on his mental state
these were just more uh
more pieces of more bricks more more
pieces uh of a building um fear that he
had of lauren canorack he became
increasingly terrified of miss cataract
and increasingly terrified of what he
believed lauren cataract could do to him
and to his girlfriend mary haskins gray
and over the time certainly over the
last month or two prior to the incident
he became increasingly terrified of what
he regarded as lauren's power to destroy
him to destroy mary haskins gray
to destroy his
farm to destroy mary haskins grace
family uh and these posts were simply
more links in to build up this this
terror
i can't point to any one post and say
this is what did it but there was an
ongoing series of posts which he found
increasingly terrifying
and is it your
opinion that each and every
host
to a certain degree played a role in his
decline of his mental state absolutely
it was a build up he became increasingly
terrified and increasingly paranoid
did you discuss with michael barrasson
lauren canarax post about going to war
yes
i'm going to show you exhibit 200 a 85
200 a 25
and 200 a
84.
can you review these and tell me if
these are some of the posts that you
discussed with michael byrosome with
regards to canorax
posting about going to war
yes these the most relevant thing about
these posts are they all occurred in
late
um
july 2019 which is within a couple of
weeks of the incident
and what effect did
those posts have on michael barrasso
there's no single post that i could say
did any single thing it was a build up
and continued to play on his fears he
became increasingly panicky if you take
any one post out of context you may say
gee maybe this is a joke or gee maybe
this is a game
but at this point he had begun to take
these posts extremely seriously and
literally and believed that she had
power to do all of these things that she
was threatening to do in the posts so
with each one it turned up the ratchet
of the pressure and mr barristone became
increasingly distraught increasingly
frightened
sure
i have all these you can handle those as
well
thank god did uh
did you discuss with michael barrasson
uh the post where larry cataract talked
about having can i ask that the witness
not be led
i'm trying not to get well
can we be heard at sidebar sure
rephrase your question please in this
regard doctor i'm going to show you
exhibit 200 a 36
200
a 53
200
a 63 and 200 a 62.
with regards to
weapons and guns
yes
can you just look at all of them quickly
i'm familiar with that i've read all
this
right and and
what impact did those posts have on
michael barrasson's mental state well
it's the same thing first of all
you have to look at the dates of these
posts uh some of them are much earlier
uh in april of 2018
so
some of this goes back
much before the actual incident so in
the first set of posts and i won't go
into reading any of these things they're
all threatening they all have to do with
guns they have to do with uh
with weapons with robbery uh with uh
you know you can take all of it
literally uh but all of it has a
threatening aspect to it so the first
set of posts the important thing is this
was april of 2018. this is more than a
year before the incident
the second set of posters
all right mr blinkers proceed in
accordance with the court's decision at
the bench please
doctor
did
you discuss with michael barrasson
post from warren canorack where she
talks about
mental health issues on her behalf yes
did you discuss with him specific posts
that he saw prior to the shooting with
regards to
lauren cataract and her
mental health issues yes counselors i've
discussed many of them after a while i
had to stop the discussion because he
would have kept me there all day showing
me posts and it just reaches a point
where it's no point yes to your answer
he did discuss specific posts about her
mental health and alleged mental health
issues
which i think this is one of the topics
i had asked if there could be a limited
instruction about
yes
i i was going to give some limiting
instructions at the end of the testimony
before your cross-examination
would you rather me give it now uh no
judge if you're inclined to give it at
the end because there's a number of
different topics i don't want to keep
interrupting any more
than i already have understood
what's necessary i'll give the limiting
instructions at the end of the direct
about any topics covered that deserve a
limiting instruction and i'll include it
in my final charge as well
doctor i'm going to show you defense
exhibit 208 77 and 208-1
and ask you
if you review these
with michael barrasso
did you review those with michael
barissell
yes i did
yeah the first thing i look at
especially with all these records is the
date is the most important thing and
you've given me uh a handful of messages
some of which were april of 2019
which would have been four months or so
before the incident and the others were
a few days before the incident in august
of 2019.
and did michael barrasson indicated that
he was
researching warren cataract at any time
yes
and did he indicate that he was
to the little objectives or leading
questions
well
i'll allow it in this area just to get
to the point
did he indicate that he was pulling up
all her facebook posts from
uh
previous periods of time he was
and and uh
with regards to
those ones you have before you
how did michael barrasson
how did those posts affect michael
barrasson's state of mind he became
increasingly panicky he became obsessed
with her posts preoccupied with her
writing and the more he dug into it the
more panicky he became
at some point in time
did you discuss with michael barrasson
his belief that he was being recorded
yes
and
and
what discussions did you have with
michael barrasson concerning that and
what effect did it have on his mental
state well he was being recorded in fact
he hired as i testified to the jury
earlier uh what called a bug sweeping
service
i saw a documentation of individual
professionals who go around trying to
find listening devices and they did
indeed find some listening devices and
in fact
i believe that lauren cataract
acknowledged placing listening devices
and some of the comments that he made in
private in his own residence somehow got
back to him in terms of a facebook post
or something like that and he became
increasingly
anxious and panicky when he saw some of
the things he was talking about in the
quiet of his home was being put on
facebook
probably through
listening devices
that increased his panic and sense of
desperation
did
did he know 100 that document
yeah this is a document from usa bug
sweeps
i guess there is such a profession
called bug sweeping and what they
there's a contract that mr barriss owned
paid five thousand dollars
to this bug sweeping company
to
check out his rather large property of
farm and stables to try to find bugs or
listening devices and they they follow
through on that contract
now
what effect did
that have on michael bauerstein
he got increasingly paranoid the more he
did to try to assure himself the worst
things got because the more he
investigated the more he found and the
more panicky he got and nobody seemed to
be able to stop it
but i'm saying nobody i'm talking about
his loved ones nobody seemed to be able
to stop it everybody noticed that he was
no longer the same person that he had
become depressed preoccupied strange odd
but
in his own mind he thought the solution
to this was investigating further and
further and further but the more he
looked the worse things gone
it was like like a house of mirrors
did you discuss with michael barristone
him hiring a
private investigator to do a background
check of cataract and goodwin he did
yeah one more one more futile effort
to try to reassure himself he hired a
private investigator
who did
some kind of background check of
cataract and goodwin when i say some
kind
i never saw a formal report
excuse me but mainly they they found
some records in north carolina okay
i'm going to lead you through this next
series of questions i'm going to show
you d
he said he said he never saw the report
he saw this judge he ain't just said he
never saw the report
doctor did you see a background check
that michael barrasson got
with regards to cataract
counselor i said i never saw a formal
report
what i saw are random records of arrests
in north carolina and some comments from
the investigator but i never saw a
formal report in the sense of a formal
investigation
i'm going to show you guys 700 a1
is this the
informal report that you
reviewed with reports mr bolenkis he
never said he saw an informal report
is this the report he never said he saw
a report he said he saw random records
and comments by the investigator these
are the records he's referring to i
believe well let him answer that
answer is
excuse me correct
these are records
that um
have to do with traffic records
okay i'm sorry you can't discuss the
content are these the records
that you reviewed with regards to
what was provided to michael barroso
these and a few others yes
now
these records
indicate that there were numerous
arrests for both individuals correct
just yes or no i i don't know how to
counter categorize humors
more than one
more than one yes your honor
and
did you discuss
those records
and michael barrasson's uh beliefs
with regards to his review of those
records
yes and his mounting panic and these
records were more embers in the fire
did you discuss with michael barrasson
him hiring a person to
sit
outside of the stable area at night
and guard the stable area he did i
believe that was larry davidson and
is that also something that fueled
well yes everything he tried to do which
on the surface
would provide some level of protection
against his perception of danger only
increased the danger and made it even
worse
did you discuss
doctor with regards to your testimony
concerning
increased danger
was that michael barrissone's impression
of what was going on yes
now
i'm going to show you
the four posts
defense exhibit 208 83
a81
986 and
900 e7
[Music]
thank you
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
these
are these four postings from lauren
cataract
postings that you
specifically talked to michael barrasson
about
again i'm looking at dates
yes these are loosely called manifesto
one two three and four i suppose
now
with regards to these posts and your
discussions with michael barrasso
can you
tell the jury how
these specific posts
affected
his mental state he believed all this
stuff
as she was as miss cataract was
gaslighting him he believed it and uh
although many of the things that his
posts i
find fantastic he believed it and he
believed it literally and he believed
that all of these things presented a
danger to him and to his family
and with each post it turned up the
screws and made him more anxious and
more panicky
did you discuss
with michael barrasson why he left his
residence
and started living in the stables
yes it was sort of a complex story but
apparently a report had been made
to the town inspection facilities
uh reporting on unsafe conditions within
the dwelling and there were two
dwellings on there and at that time he
was sharing one of the dwellings with
cataract and goodwin but there was a a
report made and it had to do with
uh unsafe conditions i never could get
that exactly straight there had been a
burst pipe at one point
there was some question about how many
people were living in the dwelling and
if there was a
adequate septic tank coverage for that
but whatever it was the bottom line was
and mr
uh goodwood mr um
barristone believed that he had been
reported to the town by cataract and
goodwin not sure who reported the town
but he believed cataract and goodwin did
that in any event the town came and they
enclosed the facility said it was
uninhabitable until remediated and he
had to leave
as did cataract and goodwin and they had
to fortunately was middle of the summer
and they had to sleep outdoors while he
remediated these problems
okay and can you describe what if any
impact
barristone having to
live outside
had on his mental state most playing
with his mind even more he no longer
could be in familiar surroundings he was
outdoors things are becoming
increasingly strange and disorienting
for him
on the day of the
incident
did you review any documents with
regards to dcpp
of coming to the farm area i did it's
dcp and p it's what dyfus is called
nowadays in new jersey basically child
protective
apparently a report had been filed with
child protective
that children these were children of
mary haskins
gray mr barristo not his children but
her children who had visited the farm
from time to time and these documents
made a report an anonymous report
because these reports are always
anonymous that these children were in
some kind of danger
and that was my understanding that two
one or two representatives of the
dcp and p
division of child protective and
permanency came down to visit and wanted
to question mr barrisson about these
allegations of abuse of these children
now
did you discuss that with michael
barrasso i did what what did he
specifically tell you with regards to
that contact with dcpp was the final
straw
what effect do you believe
that had on like american state of mind
it was the final straw
now
when you do an evaluation doc can you
explain to the jury
how you come
to what your opinion is well evaluation
is a formal exercise um what you do is
it starts with the review of records and
depending on the evaluation the records
could be really very brief maybe one
report
or they can be very lengthy like in this
case so you spend i spend a lot of time
reviewing the records so before i even
meet the examinee i'm familiar with the
records and records generally tend to be
police reports
hospital records medical records
investigation reports there can be any
kind of relevant records
this case was a little unusual because
the bulk of the records were actually
facebook postings largely from lord
cataract
but
background could be anything could be
military records whatever the records
are that is appropriate to what i'm
examining somebody for
past police records passed arrest
records i could give you a list of
records so i'll ask the attorney who
retains me whether it's a defense lawyer
or prosecutor please give me what's
called the discovery all the records so
that i can become familiar with the
facts of this of this case
once i do that i schedule a meeting with
the examinee and hold the meeting it
usually is two to three hours sometimes
depending on the complexity of the case
followed up by other meetings
during the
sessions with the examinee i take notes
and uh the notes of my own notes they
look like this they're hand written
notes
and these are notes which are not
they're not opinions but they're simply
my impression not my impressions but
what the person told me in response to
questions
i then uh put together the background
and the notes and write a report in this
case there was one single report dated
august 17 2020 after all four or five
exams were done and this report consists
of 19 pages and this contains my
diagnosis and all of my findings
there are sometimes follow-up reports
especially when new material surfaces
but in this case there was no follow-up
report there is the singular report of
august 17th
and this contains all my opinions now
subsequent to the report mr um blinkist
has given me other materials and more
postings
but it was all more of the same so there
was nothing in the additional materials
i saw that would cause me to write a
revised report a revised report would
come that there was something really
different or something i said not to be
accurate so that's the process
in that report then i have a diagnosis
and i tried to address the questions the
lawyer put to me namely what was mr
barry's own state of mind at the time of
this
shooting um and that's it uh i sometimes
get called to testify in court about
that as i am today
now
did you review anything that would that
address
uh whether or not michael barrasson was
sleeping
leading up to this event
i'm sorry that he had been sleeping
before this happened sleeping or not
sleeping although he had terrible
insomnia
if that's what well
not just what i said but there were all
kinds of witnesses on there his
girlfriend mary haskins um
ruth cox who's a family friend larry
davidson who's the man they had there
jason what's his name his assistant
trainer the young people who came
forward who were training on the farm
there must have been at least 10 or 15
people who all said the same thing that
michael barrasso looked terrible in the
last few days this was not the michael
barrison they knew that he could barely
get one foot in front of the other or
get two or three words together that he
looked as if he hadn't slept
several of these people and not not even
interested people like his girlfriend
but just kids who were training on the
farm would comment that he looked
terrible some of them thought that he
was going to commit suicide
some of them say he wasn't sleeping he
looked just horrible and this was not
the man they knew they knew him as a
tall rather heroic character an olympian
someone who was a leader someone who
trained them and he had turned into in
their words really a human wreck
now in your report did you discuss
or did you
discuss with michael barrasson
what he believed
was going to happen to him
after dc p and p came to the
farm well yes he was convinced the
children would be taken away
the children would be harmed the
children would be taken away and this
was now on top of all the other fears
that the horses would be harmed by
by a cataract in goodwin that tanaraki
guten would take away his farm take away
his possessions destroy his reputation
in the equestrian community so in
addition to all these other fears of
what cataract and goodwin were going to
do to him
all these fears which had been built up
in his paranoia there was now a brand
new fear that had never been there
before the dp and ecp
were going to take away
mary haskin gray's children and that was
the last straw that could have been
other last rose but that was the thing
that immediately precipitated his arming
himself to defend himself driving down
and having the confrontation
and did he indicate to you what if
anything he believed with regards to his
personal safety and the safety of mary
haskins they were frightened to death
they he thought that a good win in
counteracting gonna kill him
now
in formulating your opinion
did any single document or statement
control
no
no it was the build of thousands and
thousands of documents over a period of
years and really coming to fruition in
the last few months before the shooting
itself did any single interview
control
uh what your opinion uh is here today no
it did not and and everyone who tried to
intervene
was impotent to do so whether it was the
tarshish his lawyer his girlfriend
family members no one seemed to be able
to get through to him as he became
increasingly down the let's say the
rabbit hole of this abject fear that
goodwin and cataract were going to
destroy him
what what are your opinions
that you formed
reviewing everything in its entirety
mr uh
barristone in my opinion has two
diagnoses to a reasonable degree of
medical probability and diagnoses are
taken from what's called the dsm-5 which
is the fifth edition of the diagnostic
manual of the american psychiatric
association it's not a textbook but it's
a uniform set of criteria by which
doctors will agree on diagnoses
so the first diagnosis is delusional
disorder
delusional disorder
and the second diagnosis is persistent
depressive disorder
can you explain to the ladies and
gentlemen the jury what a delusional
disorder
is that we can understand all right
there are these are two very different
diagnoses and really in psychiatry
somebody can have two diagnoses just
like in internal medicine you can have
diabetes and asthma the fact that you
have one doesn't preclude the other so
people often have multiple diagnoses and
he has two
delusional disorder and the specific
type is persecutory type
is the unreasonable belief
to a delusional unrealistic point of
view that you're being conspired against
harmed
poisoned
and destroyed
now little astrix there are other kinds
of delusional disorders there's
delusional disorder jealous type that's
not what he has jealous type is where
you think that your spouse is having
some kind of relationship with somebody
that's completely unfeasible
but this is
the most common kind of delusional
disorder is persecutory type it is in
some regards like schizophrenia
schizophrenia
is a well-known diagnosis
of mental illness it's the big daddy of
mental illnesses skit he does not have
schizophrenia schizophrenia someone is
out of touch with reality
they're hearing voices they're seeing
things
they're hearing god talking to them
they are shouting they're screaming
that's schizophrenia
delusional disorder has only a piece of
that that in general his thinking is
intact
in general he's not screaming he's not
seeing things but there are islands of
his thinking which are contaminated by
delusional thinking that is everything
that had to do with lauren canara and
her family and friends was became
delusional he had unrealistic
outlandish beliefs about the things that
she would do or could do to him and no
one was able to reason him out of it
that's what a delusional disorder is a
simple delusion is a false belief
any of us can have a false belief that
we have an enemy that wants to harm us
but usually when you talk to friends and
family and you look at evidence you get
talked out of the false belief and you
realize maybe the guy doesn't like you
but he's not going to kill you
when you have a delusional disorder you
don't get talked out of the false belief
the core
false belief is that lauren canarack was
going to annihilate him he genuinely in
his bones believed that and did
everything he could to try to protect
himself against this delusion so that's
diagnosis number one
diagnosis number two is persistent
depressive disorder this is really a
chronic depression despite his
accomplishments his bravado the fact
that he looked like a million bucks when
he was in the olympics who did dressage
is basically a depressed person and this
probably has to do with the abuse he
sustained as a child on the part of his
father that we know about from his
therapist
the fact that he had two marriages that
he couldn't sustain the fact that all of
his life was professionally satisfying
there were parts of it which were marked
by sadness and depression now these two
things are not related he has a
delusional disorder which is a fairly
uncommon condition
and he has a persistent depressive
disorder which is a very common
condition
are these two diagnosis
do they meet the criteria
judge i'm going to object
to the next question
i'll rephrase it
and if we can be heard at sidebar sure
well it's quarter after why don't we
take our uh morning break and i'll
discuss you outside uh outside the
presence of the jurors so they can relax
for a little while
break ladies and gentlemen
i be seated everyone ready to proceed
that
i did hear from my staff uh staff that
one of the jurors was having some issues
seeing because of the uh barrier in a
way
all right
if that happens again just raise your
hand and uh we'll we'll have it
maneuvered unfortunately as part of the
covert protocols that they have to be in
court
because i've allowed the attorneys and
the defendant to proceed without wearing
a mask because they're on trial and
they're constantly talking and things of
that nature so because of that
we had to put those up all right i
apologize all right go ahead mr blancas
thank
you dr simmering uh do you have an
opinion to a degree of medical
probability
as to what michael barrasson's state of
mind was
at the time of the incident yes
he was psychotic and out of touch with
reality
and was he delusional
yes uh psychotic actually means out of
touch with reality so psychotic and out
of touch with reality is the same thing
they're different ways to be out of
touch with reality specifically he was
delusional he harbored a series of
interconnected false beliefs which
guided his thinking and his actions
and what did
with those respect to those delusions
what did he believe
was going to happen to him he believed
that lauren canorac and her associates
had come up with an elaborate plan to
destroy him and kill him
is there anything else with regards to
your opinion
and i referred to page 18
just the second diagnosis of chronic
depression persistent depressive
disorder this has been observed by
his therapist by other people in the
past that there is an underlying
depression
did he know the difference between right
and wrong
i'm sorry could you know the difference
between right and wrong
are you talking at the time of the
incident
time of the incident he did not know
he thought he was acting in self-defense
did he understand the nature and quality
of his acts not clear
nothing
all right members of the jury before we
get to cross-examination by mr
schellhorn i do want to give you some
certain limited instructions
based on the testimony
you just heard dr simmering of course
was qualified as an expert witness
you've heard that charge from me twice
already you're going to hear it again at
the end when i give my final charge to
you so i'm not going to repeat it
a third time now and then have to do it
a fourth time i trust you will call that
charge regarding uh expert opinion and
their ability to
render their opinions
based on information provided to them
and in that regard you have heard
reference to alleged statements made by
the defendant in the course of the
psychiatric examination by dr simran
these are considered hearsay statements
but they are allowed in this
circumstance
you should not consider these here
states uh hearsay statements as
substantive evidence relating to the
guilt or innocence of the defendant
or for the truth of the matter asserted
by the defendant in the statement
rather i instruct you to consider these
statements only
for the limited purpose of explaining or
supporting the conclusions reached by dr
simmering or for assessing the value of
the doctor's opinions that are dependent
or rely on the defendant's statements
additionally
i believe you heard a
reference
from the doctor with regard to
the prior alleged criminal history of
lauren cataract
and mr goodwin
you have heard testimony about a
background check that was done by an
investigator hired by the defendant
the prior criminal history
is
a purported one it's unverified
the defendant alleges that this
information had an impact on his mental
condition and the testimony was only
admissible
and to be only considered by you for
this limited purpose
of explaining or supporting the
conclusions reached by dr simmering
or for assessing the value of the
doctor's opinions that are dependent or
rely
on misinformation under our rules of
evidence
a jury may consider a witnesses criminal
conviction
in determining the credibility or
believability of that witness
we are not here dealing with criminal
convictions
of miss cataract or mr goodwin
there are allegations of prior arrests
those are not under our rules admissible
with regard to the credibility of miss
cataract or mr goodwin and they were not
admitted for that purpose they are only
admitted
because of the impact that information
may have had on
the state of mind of
the defendant when he received and
reviewed that information
that is the only reason that evidence
was admissible it is not substantive
evidence
of the bad character of miss cataract or
mr goodwin it's not in any way admitted
for that purpose and cannot be used by
you and your deliberations for that
purpose
the only relevance of the evidence
is the extent to which you may find it
affected the mental status or mental
condition of the defendant that's
it
there was also testimony similarly about
firearms and possession of weapons
by miss canorac referred to during dr
simmons testimony again this information
is admitted for a limited purpose only
as to the state of mind of the defendant
and how it may have affected his state
of mind that information is not
introduced because it may reflect in any
way the bad character of miss cataract
that's not the purpose of it
all right it's only limited information
either explaining or supporting the
conclusions of dr simmering or for
assessing the value of the doctor's
opinions that are dependent or relied
upon that information
all right so with those limiting
instructions i'll charge you again later
at the end of the case on the limits of
evidence but i wanted to do that now
before cross-examination since you have
heard the testimony from dr simmering
right with that we'll begin the
cross-examination by the state
thank you honor
good morning dr summers good morning mr
shellhorn
do you ever use psychological tests as
part of your examination process
yes but i don't perform them um if i
need if i think psychological tests are
helpful i will uh call upon a
psychologist colleague to perform the
testing and you'd agree with me that
even when you do use a psychological
test you would never render a diagnosis
based on the test no i would not
now you indicated uh on direct
examination that you
rendered your diagnoses
using the dsm correct i'm just going to
refer to it that way i think at this
point now the jury knows what we're
talking about uh but you would agree
that any diagnosis in the dsm would not
meet any particular legal standard that
is correct there is in fact a statement
in dsm at the very beginning that says
it in so many words that no diagnosis
equates to any particular legal
conclusion
would you agree with me that there's no
memory
disorder that's selective just for
criminal behavior that is correct
now you indicated uh that you diagnosed
mr
barristone with depression disorder and
delusion disorder correct uh you would
agree with me that depression disorder
does not affect a person's ability to
know right from wrong
well council that's a complex question
there are all kinds of
of levels of depression
i diagnosed them with persistent
depressive disorder which used to be
called the dsm-4
dysthymia and prior to that used to be
called minor depression or neurotic
depression it basically is serious
condition it could lead to suicide but
it is not usually accompanied by
psychosis
on the other hand there are major
depression disorders which can involve
psychosis and delusional thinking but
that's not my diagnosis
so in this case your your diagnosis of
depression would not have affected
michael barrasson's ability to know
right from all that is correct
i'm sorry not directly i think the
chronic depression made him more
vulnerable
to be affected by all these events but
it would not lead directly to his
ability to know right from wrongdoing
do you recall if you ever wrote that in
your report
uh i don't recall that i did
with respect to the delusional disorder
that you discussed uh diagnosing the
defendant with uh you would agree that a
person with delusions
could know right from wrong correct
a person with delusions could understand
the nature and quality of their actions
absolutely anything's possible
and i think you just testified in
response to the last question from mr
belinkus
that it's not clear whether the
delusional disorder in this case
affected mr barriston's ability to
understand the nature and quality of his
actions
correct
now i know you testified to this already
but delusional disorder is a relatively
uncommon psychiatric illness correct
some general
general questions doctor would you agree
with me that two people can have the
same experience but perceive it
differently certainly
you'd agree with me that someone being
mistaken about something is not the same
as someone having a delusion
yes in fact in the definition of
delusion one of the defining points of
delusion is it's not based on simple
ignorance
or on
cultural factors so
just for an example if a child believes
in santa claus
that's not a delusion there's no santa
claus but it's not a delusion because
it's held within the realm of children
if a person believes in god whether or
not god exists is not the point there is
a wide variety of people who believe in
god delusions are idiosyncratic they're
believed by the individual with little
of any evidence and they're held on to
firmly and the final point is the
individual with the delusional disorder
cannot be reasoned out of it
simple mistake or simple ignorance will
lead to conclusion you see something and
you believe that your partner is
cheating you out of money but when
you're shown the books and shown the
evidence
you say oh that's not true i was wrong
in a delusional disorder you could put
all the evidence in the world out there
the delusional person will hang on to
his or her delusion
and i think you just use the term
idiosyncratic can you just define kind
of how you use that word for the jury i
forgot the context in which i used it
but idiosyncratic means highly personal
that other people don't quite see it
that way
and i think you used it in the context
of a delusion would be highly
idiosyncratic it would be unique to that
person
it is now the content may not be because
people who have delusions
often have themes which are common
themes
like the theme and delusional disorder
persecutory type the theme that you're
being spied on
poisoned uh
endangered
set up for murder these are common kind
of themes but each individual who's
delusional will have his or her own
idiosyncratic take on it
doctor would you agree with me that a
person
feeling an emotion
is not the same as a delusion
we all feel emotions of course and we're
not all delusional no no we all feel
emotions and sometimes our emotions
are get us into a great deal of trouble
very common that normal people will
believe that i don't know their
girlfriend cheated on them or the
business partner cheated on them or
their driver cut them off
deliberately this is very common they
may even act on it they may even do
violence however in the long run they
don't persist when they're confronted
with the evidence they will back off mr
barrissone would not back off despite
any evidence and despite the fact that
when i mentioned before about being
spied on he was being spied on i mean
there were cameras out there but that's
not the point he thought that this was a
plot a multi-faceted plot all
designed to bring him down
and my question wasn't necessarily
specific to mr barrissone it was just a
general question that a person feeling
an emotion doesn't necessarily mean that
they're delusional i would hope not i
feel emotions every day
i hope you're not feeling any emotions
with me yet doctor only positive uh and
admiring so i mean that genuinely so let
me ask you some questions about the uh
discovery that you reviewed in this case
and uh your evaluation
you indicated that you had met with mr
barrissone for five meetings correct
and the first meeting was in person the
other four meetings were on zoom correct
do you recall approximately the total
number of hours that those
meetings were the first the total it
totaled a number of six hours in all
it's written on the first page of my
report
i believe the first session was two
hours and the others were now reached
sadly up to about six
and your first meeting with him was on
september 6 2019 that's correct
and then
which is just
just just about exactly a month after
the incident almost exactly a month
after yesterday
and then your next meeting with him
uh can you just clarify from your report
whether your next meeting was in march
or april april all the other meetings
were in april okay so on your on the
first page of your report where it says
march 13th that should be april 13th
that's a typo okay that's the title
which should be april 6th april 13th
april 20th april 27th the reason so much
time went by is i needed more discovery
material so when i had the discovery
material i broke this down into meetings
now for example
after you received the discovery
material i think one of the people you
said you reached out to was ann picardo
correct and you indicated that you
were aware that she was the defendant's
psychotherapist for periods off and on
during the years correct
ms picardo is not a doctor to your
knowledge
to my mouth she's not no she's certainly
not a physician and i'm not sure she has
a phd but and i have not seen her
curriculum vitae as far as i know she is
a psychotherapist
now you didn't review all of the
available discovery in the case did you
god
was that because it wasn't provided to
you or because you didn't want it or
need it i was choking on it i told mr uh
blinkist please stop i've seen enough
i mean i reach a point where you can get
the pattern of things without seeing
every little thing and that really got
to the whole
point of of mr barrison's problem he
would dig up every tiny little scrap i
didn't need it and didn't want it
well i wanted to ask you in particular
about witness statements i think you
indicated on direct examination that you
reviewed a number of witness statements
correct did you actually listen to the
recordings of those witness statements
or did you read police reports that
summarized this read police reports and
might have read a couple of actual
statements but i did not listen to tape
recordings now
and you were aware that there were a
number of people
that were listed in the discovery
uh whose statements were not
summarized in police reports i believe
that's true i'm not absolutely sure
there were a lot of people on the farm
a lot of young people older people on
the phone so on on the pages in your
report where you
talked about
witness statements starting on page six
those would be summaries based on your
impression of what a police officer
wrote in their report correct for the
purpose of constructing a report
it's important for me to summarize and
hopefully the summary is accurate but in
order to digest all of this kind of
information put it into a readable form
and to extract the essence of it i will
summarize things also to demonstrate my
understanding so if my understanding is
faulty then you can easily see where my
summary misses the point now obviously a
summary doesn't cover everything
hopefully the summary is accurate so if
the summary that the police officer
wrote in the report was
very short and didn't encompass
everything that was talked about during
the statement you wouldn't know that
that's correct and there are also
multiple police reports
you also indicated and i apologize i
don't know what it was marked as but
that you had re uh reviewed some written
statements from mr barrison
yes and i think you said that was 91
pages that he provided to you well he
provided thousands of pages and the deal
i struck with mr barrison i'm putting it
kindly i told mr barrison i'm not even
gonna look at it unless you give me the
hundred top hits
because i don't want more i don't need
more i don't want more you know such a
thing is so in confusion with too much
material so what he did is he complied
and he gave me a document
which consisted of 91 pages
they're not numbered they're basically
chronological mr blinkist and i went
over them and we developed our own
little dates numbering system so i have
easy reference to them but 91 pages i
think fairly
summarizes his concerns
and so that would just be what michael
barrasson wanted you to know
about his take on what happened within
the confines that you gave him well i
had everything but i instructed him to
do that
i didn't want anymore
and and i i read enough to know how
repetitive this was that i did not need
to know every single post lauren
conoract did every time she used the
word threat every time she used the word
multiple personality every time she used
the word i i wasn't interested in that
i'd seen so much of that that i got the
idea and that i wanted him to summarize
also
while it may be a biased summary in the
sense that he chose it
it's an important bias because this is
what's important to him and in my
thinking what really mattered about the
discovery is not the fact of it but what
was important to him about it so by
having him digest it i saw what was
important to him
so if he put something into his written
statement that wasn't accurate
that wouldn't matter to you well
in the summer
no record is completely accurate uh but
the
my review of the records that i saw and
his summary comported with one another
and it was not really for the truth of
anything i was really saying to him
basically go through these thousands of
pages
pick out a hundred pages the ones that
most affected you and that's what i was
interested in what most affected him
and that's what he gave me i guess maybe
asking that question another way would
you agree that if the information you
were provided was inaccurate that could
affect your diagnosis anything's
possible
so for example you were asked on direct
examination about various text messages
and and media documents that mr
barrisson told you about yes
and he told you that
he was aware of those
media posts or those uh text messages
before the shooting incident yes she was
following them avidly and so he was
following them almost in real time you
said in that weeks or week leading up to
the show
consistently following her posts
[Music]
now i'm going to show you in that regard
to find the approach
sure
what was referred to as exhibit 200 a
85 doctor got it do you remember that
post
i think i was shown this by your
adversary before this comes under a tab
they know a war is coming and where it
has a
pink highlighter around a certain post
who put that there
well i don't know put it there but it
says author lauren cataract this was on
7 28 19 that would have been a week
before the shooting and the text was
they know a war is coming and your
recollection is that michael barrissone
gave you this post in particular and
told you that this informed some of his
mental state this was part of a vast
number of things i've seen that quote
and i've seen similar quotes riddled
throughout these emails but i think your
your testimony on direct correct me if
i'm wrong was that you were shown this
particular text or that this was a
particular one mr barrisson referred to
one of them yes
and that's if you would agree with me
that's on page 18
356 of the records 18
356.
that is a lot of patience do you know
where this post came from doctor
no it looked like no i think she had
instagram as well as facebook i don't
know all the social media she used i
think her primary social media was
facebook she texted she used a lot of
social media but 18 000 pages a lot of
pages even in a case like this
would it surprise you that this came
from
facebook
sent records and this came from the
actual records facebook hack
why would that surprise me not at all
would it surprise you to know that it's
in a section called
private messages between account holders
i i have i i no it wouldn't surprise me
i don't know so if michael barissone
gave you this and said he relied on this
posting or text message
this isn't something that would have
been public at the time before the
shooting i have no idea this is one of
18 000 pages most of it's public and
this is something
are you aware whether this is something
that was turned over by the prosecutor's
office to the defense and discovery of
eighteen thousand pages i cannot account
for each one of those pages they're in
evidence i don't know anything more
about that
and i certainly did not read all
eighteen thousand pages i'm just joking
oh will i and doctor i'm just trying to
get to the heart of
michael barristone told you things you
didn't verify or corroborate everything
that he told you
i'm sorry corroborating in terms of what
well you said that he told you that he
relied on a number of facebook posts yes
that informed his state of mind
yes
and
you said that he told you about this
particular facebook post as a post that
informed his state of mind before the
shooting one of many many many certainly
i did not believe that a war was coming
and so what i'm asking you is if he
wasn't actually aware of this post
before the shooting
does that affect
your opinion about what he told you no
because he was aware of seventeen
thousand other ones which was similar
i'm just making up that number given
eighteen thousand on that so
doesn't change anything
[Music]
you were also asked about uh these posts
and i'm going to show you
what you marked as exhibit 200a
83
yes
200 a 81
manifestos
900 e6 i've read these manifestos over
and over again and 900 e7 council these
are the manifestos and i'm not going to
ask you to read them again unless you
want to doctor oh please but you
indicated that those were given to you
or referred to by mr barrison many times
and
you referred to them as the manifestos
yeah they're labeled manifesto i'm not
sure that was her word
well i now i can't even remember any
longer where this word came from
do you remember when you testified on
direct examination that lauren canaract
called those manifestos i think she did
but i'm not sure would it surprise you
to know that she never used the word
manifesto in her records i wouldn't be
surprised
doctor this is probably a small
detail for the purposes of what you were
asked to evaluate but on page five of
your report
did you indicate that the
police officers responded to investigate
on wednesday august 7 2019 at 4 30.
excuse me 4 13 p.m
uh yes that's what i wrote and are you
aware that the actual time that they
responded was 213. probably a typo
there's several typos in my report
i'm not going to go through all of them
doctor
but staying on page five you would agree
with me at the bottom of that page
it's talking about mr goodwin
and his statement
yes
and that leads over onto the top of page
six where there's a block quote of
approximately five lines yes that
actually is inappropriately attributed
to mr goodwin it's actually this
lieutenant heiner statement that came
from the report
so that's not accurate in your report
typo you also uh reviewed the number of
medical records in this case i did and
those would have been ms canorex records
as well as mr barrison's and mr goodman
and mr goblins
uh
you indicated
that mr barrissone sustained in a dog
bite on his left eye
i think thy
and i think it was in his groin area
i might have written that as i recall it
i think it was in this groin area okay
that was going to be my next question
doctors on page nine
it says he had an apparent dog bite
in his in her left eye you're
embarrassing me
i just wanted to make sure you were
looking at the right medical records the
right part of the body right
so the so that the bite as you recall it
was in his in his uh on his leg it was
just not on his eye his groin area
now you were aware uh as you testified
on direct that
dcp and p sent a caseworker to the
property on august 7th correct
and you're aware that the caseworker was
there to investigate a claim of child
neglect that's my understanding child
neglect of child abuse yes
now you also indicated that the report
uh was anonymous
uh were you aware from reviewing the
records that it was actually a report
from safe sport
later i read that initiated with safe
sport which is the sporting
uh governing body and i know as a fact
everybody in this profession belongs to
safe sport most legitimate people belong
to safe sport and it's my belief that
lauren canorack filed a report with safe
sport to
file a report against mr barrison making
more claims by the vehicle of safe sport
what i meant by anonymous is that the
actual complainant wasn't identified as
lauren cataract or anybody else it's my
experience with
child protective as they do not reveal
the names of complainants that's very
common but i i do believe it was filed
via safe sport it's by understanding
that lauren canorack had reported
you don't have to handle this doctors
thank you
but are you aware that the complaint was
actually against michael barissone and
ms gray
yes i think so
sorry to start choking
now you indicated earlier i think that
you summarized some of the witness
statements in your report i did
and
i'm going to show you
one of the
one of the remarks
this doesn't have an evidence sticker on
it
but if i could refer to this as s-147
it is marked for identification show it
to council please
doctor i know you said there was a lot
of discovery in this case so i won't ask
you if that is definitely one of the
reports that you read
let me just see if i can readily lay my
hands on that
it's a
report from morris county prosecutors
office by sasha gold i do remember that
name
and i did review that yes
doctor i'm going to refer you to sasha
ghoul there were two ghouls
investigators so i remember this is
sasha ghoul it was a male ghoul as well
that's right and doctor i'm going to
refer you to page five of that report
right approximately
i would say two-thirds to three-quarters
of the way down
it's actually the third paragraph from
the bottom that starts with gray stated
that on today's date yes
and do you see the sentence that says it
was learned that someone from her house
reported allegations of abuse against
gray's children by verizon correct
and this is in reference to
detective gould's summary
of her interview with ms ms mary haskins
gray correct
and you relied on
that summary in in formulating or adding
information to your report well
um
you said this
yes that's right this
report by investigator gould she spoke
to both mr barristone and miss gray this
statement specifically relates to this
this gray
and uh
i just want to identify the statement so
could you repeat your questions and just
before we do that you just said that
detective gould interviewed mr
barrissone and ms gray but i think you
meant she interviewed mr goodwin mr
goodwin sorry mr goodwin
right mr goodwin in this grade
so the sentence i was referring to was
it was learned that someone from her
house reported allegations of abuse
against gray's children by verison
uh yes
and then if i direct your attention to
your report
page eight
and i'll refer to your report as s 423 i
think it's the same as
the one the defendant marked yes
i have
a pg of my report of your report yes i
have it
and does the very last full sentence on
that page say
it was learned that someone had reported
allegations of sexual abuse against miss
gray's children by mr bearson correct
so you'd agree with me the only
difference between the sentence you
wrote in your report about ms gray's
interview and the sentence that sasha
gould wrote in her report about miss
gray's interview is that you added the
word sexual before abuse
oh um
yes this does not say sexual i think
that came from something else but i
don't remember this does not say sexual
here
so
beginning when you say this doesn't say
sex
what are you referring to your honor the
uh statement by investigator gould
that i was quoting
said abuse does not say sexual abuse
okay
so when you indicated earlier that you
summarized certain witness statements in
your report i think you said that that
was to give
your understanding of what some of the
witnesses said
as it may have pertained to your
ultimate opinions yeah yes correct it
allows you to point out the error that
she did not say sexual so i i laid out
my understanding which in terms of the
word sexual was not correct
so you added the word sexual into your
report where ms gray never said that in
her statement i don't know if she ever
said it or never said it but that
doesn't appear in that particular
statement and i did not add it
deliberately and that's because you
never listened to her statement or
watched your statement correct
so you added it perhaps inadvertently i
guess you're saying
based on something else you saw in the
case i think so yes
in fact in those
written
statements of michael barisson
does he continually say
that
dcp and p was there for something
related to sexually i think so
so michael verason told you in his
written statement
or wrote in his written statement that
the worker was there to investigate
sexual abuse
and then you adopted that in your report
not really uh it's my experience
counseling working with dyfus over many
years
now d c p and p is that they provide
minimal information
and they will just simply say a
complaint has been filed they won't say
by whom they often don't even say the
type of complaint and i don't know why
sexual crept into this certainly doesn't
reflect what investigator gould said it
does reflect what barristone said i
really don't know the answer to that but
i do know that some kind of complaint
was filed and i don't know who initiated
it it came via the sport safe
professional organization but i don't
know who initiated it mr
barrissone assumed that it was lauren
cataract with one more attack against
him but i have no way of knowing that
and i think you said you don't know
where that word sexual or where the
sexual abuse came from why it got
inserted here correct but
you would agree with me based on what we
just discussed the division
of child protection and permanency
dcpmp was not there to investigate
sexual abuse i don't know i'd have to
read go through this again maybe in the
break and see the statements that came
directly from the investigator if there
was a statement directly from the
investigator i'm not sure i saw anything
from the investigator what if i told you
that that investigator testified in
court earlier in this trial and said
that she was not there to investigate
sexual abuse i will accept that uh that
uh
assertion
would you also accept the representation
that the safe sport records of the
initial complaint do not reference
sexual abuse if that's your assertion i
will accept it
so where you indicated that you didn't
know where the word sexual came from
you're also acknowledging that that is
in the defendant's written statements
that he gave to you correct and i might
have conflated it in doing my summary of
the report this is really as i explained
one of the reasons i lay out my summary
so that if i am an error of anything it
could easily be picked up by you on
cross-examination
so you're putting
things that are intentionally wrong into
your report so i can catch them on
cross-examination thank martin
is that what you just said that's one of
the most bizarre things i've ever been
asked no i lay out my thinking so that
you have the opportunity to examine the
basis of my report and to question me if
i'm in error about one of the bases as
you have here
i'm not trying to trick you
and i'm not trying to trick you either
doctor
uh
now you indicated in your report on page
14
that michael barrasson told you the last
thing he remembers
is information from the social worker
cool
do you recall in that written
statement that he gave you the 91 pages
that he said
that there were two or three images
blurry at best until being unloaded from
the ambulance at morristown
if you direct me to the page sure doctor
i
i have it marked as the very last page
in those writings okay and just so the
record is clear i'm referring to what
i've marked as s40 s and 440
for identification
i have it i call it page 91.
and doctor i'm specifically looking at
the end of that paragraph and you would
agree with me page 91 is the last page
michael barrasson wrote that he gave to
you
in that so-called hundred page package
which actually were 91 pages yes what it
says is
the last two images i saw before the
lights went out actually before that
doctor what i'm referring to or it says
i remember being at my desk i have two
or three images blurry at best until
being unloaded from an ambulance at
morristown
yes i have
i remember being at my desk i have two
yes
did you ask him what those two or three
images that he remembered about the
incident work i did and i have an a red
x over that which is my notation for
meaning he could provide no further
information
on that particular four sentences i
place the red x when i go through a
statement which means you can provide
nothing else so you did ask him and he
responded he didn't remember what that
meant correct
and that's that's not in your report i
don't think i missed that correct i
didn't have these 91 pages i had 18 000
pages when i did my report and i've
already told you i did not read all 18
000 pages i'm sorry doctor that maybe i
wasn't clear
you
you didn't indicate in your report that
you asked him the question specifically
about the two or three things that he
remembered that were blurry and he
couldn't remember correct
you would agree with me that a person
who is feigning amnesia
may spontaneously confess to something
can you repeat the question sure you
would agree with me that someone who's
feigning amnesia may spontaneously
confess anything can happen if the word
you're saying is made anything may
happen
and i'm specifically
referencing in the dsm
where it talks about feigning amnesia
doesn't it indicate that an individual
who's gaining amnesia may spontaneously
confess sure that can happen
and these
statements that mr barristone wrote that
you indicated you relied on
were you with him when he wrote those i
was not
do you recall approximately when you
asked for those to be written
um
it was sometime after my last interview
in april of 2020 when i i told um mr
bulinkus that i had so much material
that i insisted that he ask his client
to prepare a digest for me
so you asked him to write those after
your last interview with him correct and
i said no more than 100 pages
and when he
protested i said no more than 100 pages
if there's anything more than 100 pages
i'm not going to read it do you recall
approximately when those 91 pages were
produced to you
sometime after my last interview in
april of 2020 and you just indicated
that after you got those uh you reviewed
them yes and you indicated that at least
with respect to the comments about two
to three images that were blurry in his
mind you asked him about those and he
didn't remember all i have is an x here
i underlined many things i do that when
i in red when i do an interview i had an
x here which meant he gave me no further
information
so you interviewed him or examined him
again
after that last meeting of april that's
listed in your report um
that's a good question i did not uh i
did not
that may have come
i might have
put that together with some of the
original
uh
material that he submitted
so it's possible you didn't ask him
about the two to three parts of the
event that he did remember even if they
were certainly possible yes
doctor moving on to your diagnosis
specifically the diagnosis for
delusional disorder
i think you indicated that a delusion is
a false belief
yes a false belief
not based on simple ignorance
not held by any particular culture of
the subculture and not amenable to
reasonable change
did you define the term delusion in your
report at all
i said
probably i did
it starts with false belief
but with those with those caveats
yes on page 18
of my report this is in the summary
section
where i wrote delusional disorder is a
relatively uncommon but severe
psychiatric illness the disorder
involves psychotic thinking
and a break with reality that's the same
thing psychotic thinking and a break
with reality delusional disorder is
related to schizophrenia which is a much
more common condition in schizophrenia
the individual displays a wide range of
serious symptoms including
hallucinations agitation
disordered thought process and delusions
however
i'm adding in delusional disorder the
major symptoms involve delusions not
these other things so in schizophrenia
you have a grab bag full of serious
symptoms in delusional disorder you just
have the delusions so it's a part of
schizophrenia
um now you well i mean i'm not finished
well in my question
and doctor my question was just whether
you defined it and i think you did
answer that well i haven't finished the
definition i didn't ask you to define it
i asked you if you did define it yes and
i was reading you my definition okay i
didn't ask for that okay thank you doc
what in particular
is is michael barisson's specific
delusion
uh that lauren counteract is bound and
determined to destroy him and kill him
when did that delusion start
i can't say exactly probably in the
summer of 2019.
and what uh
specific evidence do you rely on
to show that that was the onset of the
delusion that lauren canarack was
i don't want to paraphrase i'm sorry i
don't get the exact words you used well
the posts and his deteriorating mental
state
and their deteriorating relationship
so potentially the posts that michael
barason told you about when you met with
him correct some of which we've
established he didn't have before the
shooting
judge one not some
yeah you're just one
well i only address one judge
but if you have if you have others then
you can address them but you only
addressed one i didn't go through them
all on the break to be candid judge i
understand
but what you did go through what's on
the record is one
so doctor my question was
you indicated that you based your
opinion about the onset of the delusions
and the delusional diagnosis
on
the existence of these social media or
facebook posts well yes on the
deteriorating relationship between
counteract and barrister the things they
were saying to each other and
particularly primarily on these posts
and texts
and you didn't indicate in your report
specifically when you determined
the onset of the delusions i think i
mentioned in the report that it started
somewhere in 2019 i think after she
returned from the farm in florida and
moved back to the farm in new jersey
they had had normal problems before that
time he said normal
landlord tenant type problems but after
she returned things took a decided turn
for the worst
so if i'm reading your report right are
you talking about on page 16
where you indicate mr barrison's
relationship with lauren canaric and her
family began to quickly deteriorate in
the spring of 2019 correct
so you wrote that there because you
determined that the
delusions began then
well they
they never begin at one particular time
delusions develop and if you look at the
history of the delusion and you go
backward in time what you'll usually
find are suspicions
and distrust
and feelings about bad will these are
all within the normal intercourse
between people but then they get more
out of hand and the
ideas become less and less plausible and
more and more eccentric and more and
more idiosyncratic i think that by the
time spring of 2019
laura cataract started saying things
which were unmoored from reality unbored
from what was actually happening
and michael
barrasson was more and more believing
the things that she was saying
and you'd agree with me that the
criteria or symptom for
delusional disorder would be that the
delusion has existed for a period of one
month or longer correct
and so you what you're saying today is
even though you didn't determine
specifically whether it was before
a month before the shooting that that's
your opinion that it did exist yes
somewhere in the spring of 2019 it's
very hard to put a specific date on it
but the reason the dsm puts that proviso
in is it's to rule out an instance where
somebody suddenly claims
that all of a sudden today i became
delusional about you that's not the way
the disorder happens it percolates and
develops over time so this is a very
typical development of the delusional
disorder over time
doctor you testified on direct
examination that mr barrissone was
depressed and preoccupied
with uh
ms canara
and you
based that in part on
review of the
various facebook posts and social media
posts that he told you that he was
reviewing well that statements by other
witnesses
miss ricardo mr
tarshiss mary gray haskins ruth cox some
of the young people on the farm justin
harden i can't name all of them but
there were a lot of people who were
interviewed who were seeing the same
thing and felt helpless to do anything
about it everybody seemed to see a train
wreck coming but nobody seemed to know
what to do about it and they were all uh
preoccupied with what was going on here
between themselves and ms cannery well
not the way he was they were concerned
that's small potatoes they were
concerned i'm concerned about a lot of
things i'm sure you're concerned about a
lot of things that's not the same as
preoccupied preoccupied is having a
thought in your head that you cannot get
out of your head no matter what
that's a delusion
so if if some of those witnesses let's
say had testified that they were
terrified
or that they were scared or that they
were preoccupied with everything going
on
does that mean they were delusional too
no it depends they were certainly
preoccupied and frightened because the
farm was falling apart this is their
place of residence
and their place of employment
and they were all dedicated very uh very
strongly to a sport in which they shared
a common love and they also shared a
great deal of affection for michael
barrisson that came out
they saw everything unraveling
in front of their eyes and felt helpless
to do anything about it this had to do
with mary haskins gray and ruth cox and
i think that's one of the reasons ruth
cox came to visit i don't remember
exactly had to do with stephen tartus
had to do with justin harden people saw
from that point of view that things were
going very badly and they did not know
how to intervene
now you didn't review all of their
statements
counselor i would still be in my office
today if i were viewing every one of the
statements i took what i thought was a
fair sampling
so if somebody said something different
than what you just testified to
that could affect your opinion it has to
do with the overall thing if one
kid on the farm said gee things look
pretty happy that's not going to change
the overwhelming weight of evidence what
if all of the what if all of the people
felt the same way and expressed their
concerns the same way that michael
barisson did well
if you're saying that there that their
own fears or their preoccupations were
somehow less than michael barrasson well
it's it's
this is sort of a hypothetical thing but
if you're saying if if
justin harden said i felt personally
threatened that she was going to kill me
if stephen tarshish's attorney said i
was personally threatened that she was
going to kill me well that might be
different but nobody said anything like
that they were concerned about
barrister's welfare there wasn't anybody
else there that felt personally and
directly threatened by cataract and
goodwill
based on your review
of what you did review that's all i have
forgiven everything correct
i was given more than everything you had
access to everything
and you chose god help me yes i had
access to 18 000 pages
and it isn't just a question of reading
18 000 pages and writing a bill for 18
000 pages i'm not going to do that it's
not necessary
in doing a review of medical records
it's not necessary to do each one things
become very duplicative and after a
point especially when you're experienced
in reading records as i think i am a
pattern emerges
now that doesn't mean that on tuesday
one day somebody said things look pretty
good that wouldn't change anything the
overall picture was clear people on the
farm were concerned about the welfare of
michael barrasso and they saw the man
they really cared for deteriorating but
they were not concerned about their
personal safety it was only barrisol who
was afraid
that lauren canarac was going to kill
him he was the only one that was afraid
correct
that he was going to be killed by
kanorak now moving on uh to the question
i had about um
some of the information that mr
barristone was collecting
uh you indicated that you produced
i'm sorry
it's about i know we started a little
bit late today so i wanted to go a
little bit over but
if if if you're going to finish up
within five minutes
or ten minutes i'll continue but if it's
going to be longer i want to give the
jury there
fairly regularly
yeah all right i'm getting it
that cinch is it then doctor will break
for lunch all right very good enjoy your
lunch ladies and gentlemen we'll see you
around
20 of 2.
doctor you can leave all your papers
uh
uh
really enjoying
[Music]
i want to bring in dr simmering please
[Music]
all right good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen please be seated
we are ready to resume the
cross-examination of dr simmering
go ahead mr shellhorn thank you your
honor
good afternoon doctor
good afternoon
i think we left off uh before the lunch
break i was going to ask you some
questions about your testimony on direct
examination related to
guns
and i think you had indicated on direct
examination that you were aware from mr
barrisson telling you that there were
certain posts or social media
references to lauren cantarak owning
guns yes and he told you that he was
aware of that before the shooting yes
and i think you had indicated that that
was part of what you relied on
uh in rendering your opinion or forming
your opinion that he was delusional at
the time of the shooting
that he believed a lot of this and all
this led into delusional thinking
now you were aware from your review of
the discovery that mr barrissone had
called 9-1-1 on a number of occasions
leading up to the day of the shooting
yes at least four occasions do you
recall did you listen to any of those
911 recordings i did
do you recall on the july 31st 9-1-1
call
when he was asked whether any weapons
were involved or mentioned and his
response was no that's
correct and you recall on august 1st
when he called 9-1-1
he was asked if weapons were involved or
mentioned and his response was no i
believe that as i recall that was true
and on august 3rd do you recall that he
called 9-1-1 and was asked if weapons
were involved or mentioned
and his response was i have not heard a
word of that
something like that yes those are
standard questions and i believe he
answered in the negative
and lastly on august 5th on the call he
was asked if weapons were involved or
mentioned and his response was
not so far that's correct not so fun
that's correct
now
doctor i think you testified earlier
today that the gun
that was recovered after the shooting
was ruth cox's gun
correct
do you recall in your report that you
had said a number of times that you
assumed it was mary haskins graze gun
if i did it was a mistake i think it was
dr cox's gun
and i think if you can refer to page
nine
of your report
specifically halfway down the page
before the heading that says medical
reports yes
did you put in brackets there i believe
the gun was a pistol that belonged to ms
gray
uh
i'm sorry give me the reference please
yes sir it's uh page nine
the last line before the heading oh i
have it i think that was an error i i
think that it belonged to dr cox
and on page 14.
you indicate at the bottom of the page
in the last paragraph he had in his
possession a small pink pistol which i
believe came from mary haskins again i
think that was an error um
i remembered clearly it was a pink
pistol
not to be sexist about it but it looked
like a quote woman's pistol and uh it uh
it belonged to one of the women and i
must have had that mixed up when i
dictated the report i i'm almost sure it
came from uh dr cox
so we don't have to go through the
exercise again would you agree with me
on page 17
if it says i'm not certain when he
obtained the small pink pistol which i
believe was owned by ms gray
that would be the same answer yeah i
think it was my error i think it was dr
cox
were you aware from your review of the
discovery that there were multiple
places where it was referenced as ruth
cox's gun
i think so
you'd ever asked michael barasone when
he first obtained that gun did you
well yes uh he he said that he obtained
it it had been locked up in a safe as i
recall and he obtained it shortly before
he uh went down to confront
um lauren cataract at where she was
living and he armed himself because he
was frightened for his life
and he as i recall he removed it from
his safe where it had been kept for
safekeeping can you show me or tell me
where in your report you put that
that
well so your recollection is that you
asked michael barissone when he first
obtained a gun yes i might be able to
find it in my notes not in the report
or it might be in the police report i
don't remember
would you
take my word for it that it's not in
your report yes i will
so your recollection is that at some
point when you were interviewing michael
barrasson
he told you that he remembered getting
the gun from the safe
before he went to the house yes
and at least for purposes of your
cross-examination you agree with me
that's not in your report
i i'm not going to look through it and
waste the jury's time i'll accept your
representation
did you ask him when he first obtained
the gun from ruth cox
uh from what i recall
she had come up from north carolina to
visit
and uh she gave it to him for
safekeeping and he put it in this safe
would you agree with me that that's not
in your report either no that's not the
report and as i recall i don't know if
it was a licensed weapon and i think
that the safe keeping he put it in his
safe
that's my best recollection of it
so your recollection from
reviewing the discovery and speaking to
michael barisson
is that
you knew that ruth cox had brought the
gun with her from north carolina
had given it to the defendant for
safekeeping he put it into his safe
he got it at some point before the
shooting before he went to the farmhouse
that's my best understanding yes and
none of that is in your report correct
and you continually attributed the gun
to ms greg throughout the course well
that was an error it was dr cox's gun
no further questions josh what
redirect
dr uh the prosecutor asked you uh
questions on cross with regards to
where you got the
statement
concerning
sexual abuse
allegations made to dcp correct yes
did you review the safe sport
complaint filed by lauren cataract i
never saw that complaint i was aware of
it through the police investigation but
i never saw the complaint
um
prosecutor asks you questions about
feigning what is fainting fainting is
faking
okay and uh
did you consider
uh
whether or not my client was feigning
based on
your interviews with him and reviewed
the
well it's always a consideration in a
forensic interview especially when the
stakes are high and feigning or
malingering which is another form of
feigning can be done for any number of
reasons it could be done in a simple
civil context
where somebody feigns injuries to get a
reward say an insurance settlement or
something like that or somebody can
feign facts in a case to avoid criminal
responsibility so in evaluating anybody
feigning or malingering is something
which is always a consideration okay and
in your consideration of that
did you find any evidence
based on everything that you did
to indicate that michael barrasson was
feigning about not remembering the event
i i hate the word any because eddie is
like any
i don't know maybe he twitched his left
eye and that would be seen by some
people as evidence
if you're asking me did i find any
significant evidence that he was faking
the answer is no
nothing
well you may step down doctor thank you
thank you
i call your next witness
so
[Music]
all right doctor good afternoon please
leave me alone please remain standing
left your way ahead of me left hand on
the bible right hand please listen to my
court clerk do you swear in the presence
of almighty god that the testimony gives
to this court regarding this matter
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth i do please state
your nameless by your last name my name
is charles hassan h a h-a-s-s-o-n thank
you all right you may have a seat doctor
please keep your voice up nice and loud
go ahead mr blanca's direct examination
good afternoon good afternoon
where do you currently decide
in
new jersey ridgefield new jersey
and what's your profession what do you
do for a living i'm a licensed
psychologist in new jersey and in new
york state
and how long have you been a licensed
psychologist over 30 years
and
what's the difference between a
psychologist and a psychiatrist a
psychiatrist is an individual has an md
degree
a psychologist has a phd psychologist
doesn't prescribe medication the
difference in the two is in my opinion
the psychologist has more training in
therapy
and also in psychological testing the
psychiatrist more has a training in the
biological basis of mental illness
can you give a brief description of your
educational background okay
well i received my bachelor's and my
master's degree in psychology
subsequently i went to boston college i
received a phd in educational psychology
during the time i was there
i did a
internship at a hospital new england
medical center
it was an interdisciplinary program with
four psychiatrists for psychologists and
for social workers
while at
boston college
well actually while at the tufts program
my supervisor had just graduated from
rutgers university and did research on
infant memory
and i asked her if i could contact her
supervisor i did my dissertation on 11
week old babies
okay
can you give us
your background with regards to any
agencies that you were affiliated with
with regards to your use of url
well for a number of years i worked i
did reports for hudson county superior
court approximately 1200 to 1500 reports
of a number of years i was working for
the rossi group at that time
subsequently i became an administrator
at hudson county jail
for three years i saw patients i had my
office on the unit
they were all psychiatric patients there
during the time that i saw the patients
and treated them i also did further
reports for the superior court i also
did
work at a day hospital program for three
years for aggressive children i
developed the programs there
i also worked over 20 years for social
security disability
doing disability assessments they
involve psychiatric psychological memory
and concentration type of assessments
and
i also work currently at
a long-term care facility
uh in which i'm a neuropsychologist i
provide direct care and i also uh go out
and interview prospective
uh patients like at greystone and other
places
i'm part of a team with a mental health
director i'm the director i'm the uh
chief psychologist on the mental health
unit
there's two two units there for mental
health one with really severely impaired
individuals that have behavioral
problems many of them have dementia and
then there's other people who have like
schizophrenia schizoaffective disorder
and i work with them too and they also
see other patients throughout the
building have you ever worked for daifus
yes i have over what did you do for them
i did uh psychological assessments for
diaphys for a time i also worked for the
peru unit that's the uh the parents uh
attorneys
and then i also did some work for the
guardian ad litem
how about work for
either police or correctional officers
actually uh when i worked for the rossi
group i did psychological assessments on
law enforcement they were
police
firemen
and also uh did reports for
private uh
police departments if a police officer
was depressed or had some kind of
difficulties i made a recommendation
either to allow them to have their
weapon or have it taken away for a
period of time
i also have done work for
different prosecutors offices and
private attorneys this last year i did a
report for passaic county prosecutor's
office on a cruel case i appeared in
court about three times
via
video
and it was on a complicated crawl case
and the last two years i did
approximately nine private cases
including that one did you ever do any
uh
psychology work in the hudson county
jail well i was the administrator there
i was i was hired by a psychiatrist
i coordinated all treatment
on the unit i scheduled the psychiatric
care and as i said i had my
office right on the tier with the uh
the inmates
during the span of your third year
career approximately how many
evaluations have you done
many thousands
of evaluations
so i would estimate anywhere between 8
000 and above
and
did most of those evaluations involve
psychological testing yes
have you ever testified as an expert yes
i have in federal and state court in new
jersey and out of state
for both
prosecutors offices and defense yes
judge at this point
i offer
dr hassan as an expert
in psychology
all right
prosecutor do you have any questions as
to the qualifications of dr hassan not
at this time judge i'll ask him
and do you have any objection to the
court qualifying him as an expert in the
area of psychology
all right based on the testimony of
dr hassan with regard to his education
his background his work history training
i do find that he's an expert in the
area of psychology pursuant to rule 702
in the new jersey rules of evidence and
he will be
committed to render his opinion i do
find he does possess some specialized
knowledge that will assist the trier in
fact
in making determinations necessary in
this case
so qualified go ahead mr belinkus
uh doctor uh were you hired by the
defense to do an evaluation of michael
barrasso
and
specifically
can you set forth what you were hired to
do well broadly speaking the goal was to
assess his mental state at the time of
the shooting on august 7th 2019
but more specifically to determine
whether he suffered from
a mental disorder as referenced in the
diagnostic manual
which impaired his thinking to the
extent that he could not appreciate
his actions
and if he didn't know what his actions
were did not know what he was doing was
wrong
he did not know the nature and quality
of his actions
did you
physically meet with michael barrison
yes how many times i met with him seven
times
and uh did you put the dates in your
report as to when you
met with him yes but are there any
mistakes with regards to
yes there are mistakes there i met with
him explain
when you met with him
and for how long i met with him on
october 29th
november 5
november 6
november 19
november 20 december 4 december 5
for a total of 37 and three-quarter
hours
in addition to meeting with michael
barristone for 37 plus hours
did you
interview anyone else
i interviewed his
former therapist
dr
picard
p-i-c-a-r-d i misspelled it on my report
all right and
how long did you
interview her 45 minutes i also reviewed
some notes she sent me
including um text messages back and
forth between mr barrison and her over a
period of time
and and why did you feel it necessary to
interview
uh
mr picard cardo
well i wanted to find out whether she
had whether he had any uh prior
vulnerabilities
that would uh influence the possibility
of going from
an earlier
psychological vulnerability state into
psychosis
now
why is that important to you
with respect to your evaluation
well there's a great deal of research
that shows that many people in the
general environment have what the
pre-psychotic features
and if they're placed in a very
stressful circumstance they could
convert into a psychotic
situation
in his case she said that
while he appeared to be
healthy strong
and
imposing six foot three or six foot four
she said he was a very vulnerable person
and that
he suffered from long-term psychological
problems including depression suicidal
thoughts
she noted that there was a time when he
was in europe i think 2015 or 2016 in
which he spoke to her by telephone
stating that he
had researched getting um
assisted suicide in switzerland for ten
thousand dollars and she was able to
talk him out of
the suicide attempt or not attempt the
actual suicide but she said that
basically um
he uh suffered from a lot of emotional
instability she praised him as having
good features of his personality but at
the same time she gave a non-varnished
opinion about him saying you know he had
good points and some difficulties
do you reference your interview with uh
ricardo on page nine
yes
what if any other information
that was relevant to your evaluation did
you obtain from uh
carter she said basically that he was uh
paranoid on the fringes
i'm sure she didn't know the actual term
but it would be pre-psychotic he had
features of an individual who could
develop psychosis if he was placed under
sufficient amount of stress
and did she indicate anything with
regards to
his history as a
child small boy
well he had a difficult childhood
um he had a
rough upbringing with his mother he was
emotionally
abusive and also likely physically
abusive and he struggled
he made his uh he made a successful life
but you know he had a great deal of
difficulties he was also sexually
assaulted as a child
now what impact if any
would those circumstances have on your
evaluation of michael
well individuals who tend to convert
from pre-psychotic to a psychotic state
have those features of having emotional
instability having a childhood history
of abuse and also being sexually
assaulted
it would be a vulnerability that could
magnify the effects of outside pressures
did
miss piccardo indicate the length of
time
that she had treated michael barrasson
on and off she treated him on and off
for 20 years
she said approximately the last two
years she hadn't treated him but before
that she treated him for she treated him
six years earlier for about three years
straight
yeah
in addition to your
clinical interviews of michael barrasson
and
your interview of picardo who was
treating michael barrasson did you do
any psychological testing yes i did
personality
cognitive
neuropsychological but most important i
did validity testing divility testing
looked at personality tests to see if
they were valid and also at cognitive
assessments see if they were valid
such as memory
okay
with regards to the mmpi ii
what is that
the mmpi 2 is an objective personality
test two false questions
and um
well there's a total of 567
and um two false questions
it's uh
the it's
i did the mmpi two i scored that
and uh basically it has ten clinical
scales
uh each has a different name so what do
those clinical scales
measure they measure uh
psychological problems such as
depression anxiety schizophrenia mania
etc
and do each of those components look at
different aspects of someone's
personality yes they do
and again
so the jury understands
what are those ten separate areas that
are around well the scales have
different names but scale one measures
somatic complaints physical complaints
scale two measures depression
scale three measures a concept called
hysteria scale 4 measures psychopathic
deviance
it sounds scary but it could be made up
of
family and emotional problems scale 5
measures
sex identification scale six measures
paranoia scale seven it's called
sarcastinia but it measures anxiety
scale eight measures of thought disorder
schizophrenia it's labeled scale nine
measures mania
the mean on the test the middle score is
50. if you go above 65 it's significant
every 10 points above that is a standard
deviation
and in this particular case mr barazon
scored extremely high
on scale six he had a t-score of 90. and
what is tail six again
paranoia i'm sorry
and
he scored what on that scale 90. and
can you explain what a score like that
means to someone like you in your
profession it means that if we went in
this whole building
there would probably be
0.001
people who scored as high as that it's
extremely rare but the important part
about that is that the validity scales
did not show any feigning
you mentioned the word validity scales
can you explain that so the jury can
understand what you're talking about
every test should have validity to see
whatever conclusions are made are
accurate if the test is
doesn't have good validity scales it can
come up with any statement but on the
mmpi it's basically one of the gold
standards in the united states and in
the world
uh for uh testing personality he did not
he
did not show fainting he answered
genuinely honestly and he had a very
high score on paranoia
and then when i looked at the components
of paranoia persecutory ideas it's
called pa1 i believe the score was 105
if i'm not mistaken that's even higher
and what does that 90 score and that 105
score indicate to you as a psychologist
with regards to michael
barrasson's mental state well not just
to me any psychologist who did work on
the um mmpi would look at that to say
that there's a very high likelihood of a
delusional disorder
a psychosis a break with reality
how did you score that
test i ran it through a computer program
made by psychological corporation
i gave it what they call extended scores
and are there other ways to store that
test yes using that computer program you
could hand score it but it's best to do
the computer scoring then i looked at
additional um scales on there there's
one
program by alexander caldwell
that is a ratio between neurotic
and psychotic
traits he had a high score on that an 88
school
that suggests
that he's very prone to making
idiosyncratic
uh unusual deductions about events in
the real world that would fit in with
being paranoid there's information out
there and he combines it in a way
that
doesn't make sense
and
that's all
data
and
scores that you got from the mmpi
yes paranoid anything else from the
from that specific test well he had a
high score on anxiety
anx he had a high score another score on
biz number two
that shows bizarre slightly bizarre
thinking
there's different types of delusional
disorder he has a delusional disorder
two not a one one would be in
schizophrenia his type of delusion
is a non-bizarre type of delusion
what's the difference can you explain
that to the jury what type of delusion
that test is pointing to
well a test would pick up both
if he had a high score on scale eight
which is schizophrenia and a high score
on six it would suggest that he has some
type of schizophrenia variation it would
be a type one delusional disorder but he
didn't have that
his type two delusional disorder like
the schizophrenia type
uh you cannot make sense of why the
person's experiencing that but on a type
one
there's some event in the environment
that the person is experiencing and is
giving it an odd type of spin
but there's something out there that
could make sense to you so if you're in
your living room in your house and the
people above you are making noise
on one hand you could say well it's the
children
from like a rank frolicking around on
the floor on the other hand you could
say that
someone has brought in some
super machinery that is making the noise
because they're trying to probe the
people underneath
you know and get secret information
so there's a noise out there but the way
that the person interprets it is off
now
did you score uh
michael barrasson with regards to the
raw shock inkblot test yes
and can you explain that test to the
ladies and gentlemen of the jury the
rorschach inkblot test was developed in
1921 by hermann rorschach it's
ten inkblots initially was 41 inkblots
but the
publisher didn't want to spend the money
so they just kept 10. and it was a game
in germany at the time
that uh
you would show the picture of an inkblot
and ask the person what it is
in any event i scored it according to
one of the the current systems the exner
system
and basically came out showing that he
is uh emotionally unstable
um
he
has difficulty coping with stresses in
the world around him
part of the problem with his coping is
he switches from overly emotional to an
overly ideational or cognitive
way of handling it but he's not behaving
consistently so because he doesn't
behave consistently two things happen
the people in the environment can't time
figure him out how he's going to behave
and also because he's switching back and
forth he doesn't really work things out
you know to come to a conclusion
how is that rorschach that test scored
well you uh measure where
the person is shown an ink plot and you
say what might this be
and then after that you ask them where
on the inkblot they saw it then you
asked them what about it made it look
like a bat so they may say it's the the
form it's dark ink or black or something
like that
and you score that the determinants so
you score the determinants for form
color movement
and um
and there's a whole bunch of other
variables there
you know on that you can score
so um um how reliable is that test
doctor well it's not like the mmpi how
however it's it's good in terms of
explaining
a person's way they see the world around
them their perception and their
cognition
but it's it's not meant to um
uh
find out if a person has a delusional
disorder because you could be the
unabomber right and come up with a very
clean profile
you know because the person could say
well i saw a bat over here so this uh
that over there but it doesn't really
speak to the issue of
of uh the way he's thinking
is there any
validity
portion of that test
uh
to determine its accuracy well if you're
going to do that test you have to do it
to a t you just can't do it you know
partially
and uh the the idea behind all of the
testing
is you do a whole host of testing to see
if there's an overlap or agreement in
the diff different tests so you don't
hang your hat on the mmpi alone although
that's a strong test
and you don't hang your hat on anything
else but to see if there's coherence
there was coherence
uh between the rorschach and these other
tests that i did the rorschach indicated
another quality of mr
michael
was that
he has uh a tendency to put together
various pieces of information that are
discombobulated and form it together to
come up with an idea it's over inclusive
thinking and i found that when i spoke
with him
and i also found that on other testings
other than the mmpi
did you do any other psychological
testing i gave another test called the
pai personality assessment inventory
uh
that's a
test similar
to the mmpi but it's different uh
technically
and um but it's a it's a solid test
uh the validity scales were within
normal limits
i used rogers uh there's a famous
american um
psychologist who's done has done a lot
of the work on malingering and deception
i used his cut scores
for that test
and it was not it was genuine the way he
responded
the summoned substance of that test was
he was high on uh paranoid thinking
ideas of persecution and he showed
effective instability the effective
instability was picked up by
um a possible um
diagnosis of borderline um
personality disorder but that's neither
here nor there the main point is that he
had effective instability where his
emotions can be discombobulated kind of
quickly under pressure
did you do any validity testing well it
has validity testing on it on there
one is called the ni plane
what validity testing within a test
deals with the levy testing
can determine if an individual
is manipulating his responses whether
he's
overly reporting pathology or under
pathology
it can tell that right give an example
so the jury can understand
well uh suppose like i'm trying to um
there's no diagnosis of malinger
but suppose i'm trying to feign
uh some
fake what you're saying fake if i'm
trying to fake something that test could
pick it up
and how does it do that
uh it has scales that have been uh over
the years been
determined to pick show that right
so uh some some scales can pick up
whether a person is uh
claiming excessive amount of
positive characteristics that most of
the people in the
world will not
claim like i never lose my temper
there's other things that there's other
ways to do that but
the pai
the mmpi have the strongest validity
scales
did you do any other validity testing
yes what i did uh a test called the
sirs-2 s-i-r-s-2
it's a revamping of service one
um what they wanted to do is to cut down
on false positives so if someone was
let's say feigning amnesia or something
like that or feigning some psychiatric
condition they didn't want to have false
positives so what a false positive is if
you go into a jail there's a
magnetometer and every time you go
through it if it rings makes a buzz
because you have a back problem at
surgery metal in your back
that has a high sensitivity but
it has
it's not a specific
you're not bringing in a gun or anything
like that so rogers and his associates
when they developed it they wanted to
have a test that had strong specificity
so that you wouldn't get false positives
on that particular test
verizon did not show any feigning he
scored
honestly
any other validity testing well there
was two others i did two other uh
personality tests they look at
personality from a different perspective
why did you look at a personality test
in evaluating
well for the simple reason if you're a
forensic psychologist or psychiatrist or
whoever it might be you want to make
sure that you're not being misled
having your own biases you want to look
at
the person you're interacting with and
you don't want to
be skewed in a certain direction so i
like to do a lot of testing to see if uh
i'm missing something so the tests have
leading scales i might say well someone
is uh perfectly you know well or not and
if the testing is comes out in a
different way i have to scratch my head
and look more deeply
did you do any personality tests
and
if so what specific tests did you do
well as i mentioned i did the mmpi the
rorschach the pai they all look at
abnormal
aspects of personality but i wanted to
compare it
to other tests that look at normal
personality
because why did you want to look at that
because i i wanted to check on my own
views to see if i was accurate to see if
these other tests were accurate that's
called construct validity i want to
check it out what does that mean explain
that to the jury
well um there's a concept in psychology
called multi-trait matrix and what that
means is you want to give multiple
measures from different situations and
to see if they all agree with each other
right if there's agreement you can say
well you know what that may be an
accurate uh
finding
and so it's a check
i do the testing as a check on myself
and also a check on the test the two
other tests that i gave measure normal
traits if you have an excess
or
a low amount of a certain trait it can
cause psychological problems those two
tests agreed with the mmpi and the pai
and also the rorschach basically um
on the uh 16 pf it's um
it's developed on a person a
factor analysis approach but anyway
there were four ele four elevations on
that test if i'm recalling you know
clearly
one was called uh q4 is a very high
level of anxiety and depression
another
was very low score on c
this test divides
all of the scores in tenths
there's ten one two three there's ten of
them
if you have a score of one or a score of
ten that's a very uh elevated score
either way
now the score that on c
was
emotional instability he had a score of
one which is similar to the rorschach
and similar to the other test that he's
unstable emotionally he could be
uh emotionally upset
uh a little more easily than other
people
and did the tests that you've uh
testified to so far all
coincide with each other as far as the
bottom line
yeah they did and what does that tell
you from a practitioner's standpoint
emotionally unstable
other tests
indicate that he could easily be moved
into a
psychotic state psychotic stages to
break with reality
and uh some of the tests show that he
has very idiosyncratic thinking
the rorschach showed the over-inclusive
thinking it's a technical term but all
it simply means that if you meet with uh
michael barrasson and you're talking
with him it's really hard to do a
clinical interview with him because he's
all over the place
so um
anyway
did you do any cosmetic tests yes i did
and again why would you do a cognitive
test in a
psychiatric evaluation because when i
came in and i tried to interview him and
uh and by the way the reason i did it
over seven sessions
was it's very hard for someone to play
act over a long period of time if you
see someone who's play acting there's a
movement towards normality
as time goes on because it's hard to
keep up the act
there was no change with him he was uh
crying sobbing at one point
the officer was outside he he called me
over and said are you okay because he
hurt him like
ranting and raving he was very upset
and
because of that i suspect that he had
some kind of problem you know
neurologically or with attention or
whatever it might be so i decided to
investigate that okay and is that why
you did cognitive tests yes what
specific cognitive test did you do well
first i gave a full iq test because it
could tell you if he has deficits in
certain areas
the test is called the wechsler
intelligence scale and there's a part on
it that measures verbal abilities
non-verbal ability working memory where
you could do two things at the same time
whistle and uh
you know play guitar
being facetious but it measures uh two
cognitive things at the same time psycho
motor speed and it also gives a full
scale iq
i gave that i found out that on that
testing he has a problem with uh working
memory it's a variation of attention
and uh then i also checked
out his
verbal iq is up here
and his working memory is over here it's
20 points lower
you know what does that tell you
is it it's a relative deficit
in working memory attention
um and how does that relate to your
evaluation
and i also asked him about his childhood
he said that he always had trouble
maintaining focus in school right but i
noticed that when he'd be talking to me
he would be repeating himself
constantly as if like he couldn't
remember what he just said
and then he'd be all over the place
and it was very hard to keep up with him
so the way i did it was
i ignored
any extra talk and i wrote down
phrase by phrase and then when i came
back to it i said well you just said
such and such and i continued that way
it was a little bit more tedious but i
can get a comprehensive
interview done with him
now because i saw that there was a
problem with working memory and aspects
of attention
so like for example um
uh if you say to him give me digits
forward he could do pretty well on that
five or seven between five and seven
digits forward
and then i said dude backwards
like um two four he's supposed to say
four two he could only do three for
someone who's as intelligent he's an
intelligent person intelligent as him it
was a low score
so then i looked at
attention and i gave one test
to check out attention and
his school is
the
cpt the conners continuous performance
test
and um
he scored so low
on it i was surprised so i gave it to
him three times and he scored as if he
was neurologically impaired with an
intentional problem or you know a
diagnosis of adhd
then i wasn't
i didn't stand on that test alone
so i also gave another test called the
act
it's uh auditory consonant test so it's
something like this
you say to the person
three consonants like i'm just making
this up a b c
and then you say 200 and the person has
to count backwards by threes
200 197 194 191 all the way back then
you get to either 9 or 18 or 36 seconds
you say what were the three words
and uh
usually a person would say abc with
michael he scored at the first in the
second percentile level it was a low
score they know that
he has an intentional problem he's all
over the place he's like scattered
the scattered quality has i started
picking up when i was talking with him
he'd be uh saying to me wait a minute i
gotta tell you this i gotta tell you
that and his thoughts
were not linear it wasn't like he was
following you know in a way that i could
follow easily it was difficult you know
to follow and what could cause
someone to score or react like that well
it's
it's hard to say 100 percent because he
has um had a fracture of the skull when
he was age eight
he also had eight to twelve uh
concussions falling from a horse
uh dr ricardo
mentioned to me that he also fell when
he was roofing his house and she said
that
he was too macho to want to go into the
hospital he used to do a lot of
construction around his property but
it could be from the fall it could be uh
some other developmental problem right i
don't know but he has he has an
intentional problem and his thoughts are
scattered
okay and
in reviewing the discovery uh did you
review the injury
that michael barrasson suffered in this
incident yes
and
what if any impact
could they have had on his uh
neuropsychological testing
well um
he has no memory for the incident
and in my report i noted a reputable
neuropsychiatrist cummings from
california he gave two examples he said
that gene tony who was a price fighter
who fought against dempsey he dropped
out of boxing
because he started having
amnesia periodic bouts of amnesia and
then and the doctor gave the uh an
example of another price fighter who was
fighting a fight and from the fourth
round on he didn't even know he won the
fight until hours later he had to be
told
so he was uh to me he looked like he
lost the mixed martial art fight he had
uh
severe bruising in his face
he had uh
bleeding under the left ear i think
bleeding from the right eye
and
he looked like he had he was given a
workout now it's possible
that the uh the beating you know
affected his memory i can't say 100
percent
but
um
it may have impaired what they call
consulate consolidation you know
but
would his previous uh head injuries that
you mentioned
uh
impact on a subsequent uh have an impact
on subsequent yes because if you look
you feel like a price fighter and you
get beaten a lot of times
um let's say later in life you hit your
head it could uh have more of an impact
than if it was the first time the more
prior blows to the head especially in
the front of the face or wherever he got
hurt
it's going to have a greater impact than
just one beating
now
did you test for executive functions yes
what are executive functions well
the executive functions i looked i tried
to look at it like differently
executive functions are like
organization uh planning
things of that sort he scored well on
that i also gave him a test among the
executive functions that picks up if
there's some form of brain damage either
acute or diffuse he didn't have any
problems with that
the only thing that i did notice in
terms of executive functions you know
and i uh
i looked at it is that
he has some kind of nonverbal visual
problem
and like if you ask him to draw a
pattern a complex pattern he doesn't
draw the outside he draws like a little
bit of it it's as
as if he has trouble forming a visual
picture of something i don't know if
that's from the and it's unusual i don't
know if that's from the uh head trauma
or what
but um people who tend to have some kind
of executive dysfunction sometimes when
they
uh try to do a task they don't organize
it his was like all over the place in
that regards
any other tests all right so um because
he claimed that he had amnesia for the
event first of all i also wanted to do
uh validity testing so the most
important validity testing for cognitive
is the vip
and it showed
no
feigning on either when you say validity
testing
you administered a specific test
to determine whether or not
michael barra batterstone was feigning
faking faking
not remembering the event
i wanted to see because people who are
feigning they typically try to claim all
manner
of
memory impairment they over play their
hand
he didn't do that his memory was not not
terrible or anything of that sort
and on the
vip it came out that he was honest and
genuine except i have to say this
on one part of the vip is a non-verbal
part it indicated there's a computer
program on there that had trouble
maintaining his attention on a
non-verbal on the non-verbal part of the
test
but even with that it came out that he
was conclusively
genuine in how he responded he showed
effort and intent to do well on that
test and what does that
have to do with your opinion as to
whether or not he's saying
he wasn't feigning memory impairment and
if he's claiming that he can't remember
you know i
um
i tend to uh by what he's saying except
that i don't know if it's
um from um psychogenic i put down this
dissociative amnesia from stress
but it could be from the beating it
could be from the uh prior head injuries
or what
so
it could be either
from a physical injury or from a mental
yes
and if i might interject i just wrote a
recent uh review article
that it was uh from
a university in holland
that i've done
the program is like criminology there
and they studied
20 years of worldwide
claims of dissociative disorder they
looked at the
studies themselves and the problem is
that the people who did the studies they
didn't rule out tbi a lot of people had
like what's tbi uh traumatic brain
injury they had mild traumatic brain
injury and they didn't real rule that
out as the reason the person couldn't
remember
so in his case i put down that he had an
emotional type of loss of memory
but
he also had you have to keep in mind
that he had a beating
did you do any memory tests yes i did
and um and why did you do a memory test
when you were evaluating michael barry's
own state of mind at the time of the
incident well
first of all i wanted to see if he had
some kind of significant brain damage
that can influence the results and like
i just said that people who are feigning
amnesia or memory impairment
they tend to overplay their hand
so they have memory impairment all over
the place his actually was very specific
in one little area and that was
non-verbal memory
and were there any validity
portions of those tests
well the validity was the vip i also did
another test called the cvlt and i also
did another test called the tom the cvlt
is a list learning test
and it has a validity component built
into it the bottom line is that he was
not feigning on
that test on the tom which is non-verbal
memory
uh recognition memory he had a poor
school
i i didn't know whether it was from the
fact that he had problem with non-verbal
memory
or what
but you know
he was given four tests three out of the
four came out fine that the the vip is
the most powerful one
of those different tests
fine
he was not uh feigning
did you do any perceptual tests i did
which ones
uh well the tests that i gave were from
the um the nab
that's the neuropsychological assessment
battery so you have a whole bunch of
tests on that then i supplemented that
with some other tests
that i gave i gave a test called the ray
complex figure test on that test i saw
that he he worked very piecemeal in
terms of putting things together he also
has a memory component on that he scored
poorly in terms of memory for non-verbal
um his perceptual functioning was
borderline and a couple of tests i don't
know if uh you know if i did more
assessment with him which i thought was
like uh
i didn't see the utility of it but you
know maybe i could determine exactly
what the problem is with the non-verbal
functioning
and finally did you do uh any tests with
respect to language i did and why would
you test
or give him language because you have a
beating to your front of your head and
this is like the frontal area of the
skull
uh it could damage uh your verbal
production so if you say to an
individual i'm going to give you uh 60
seconds
and tell me as many words that begin
with the letter f a
f i s first with f don't give me
people's names like fernando don't give
me places like france don't give me
numbers like five
and you total it up there's um
tables that are based on age education
ethnicity and he scored very fine
average score is between 12 to 15 words
per minute and he was like 18
18 per minute so
from the beating he had it didn't affect
that language production area okay now
you've testified to a great number of
tests that you administered
were they
were the tests consistent with each
other
the tests were consistent in showing no
feigning
no feigning on personality or cognitive
and
what else
did the test
indicate to you based on your scoring
the test the tests indicate that he
suffers from
paranoia delusional disorder
of a very high
level
and that uh
it's very significant
all right um
now did you
review dr simran's evaluation yes i did
and did you review that stack of uh
91 pages that were provided yes i put
down 51 but i don't know exactly what
the number is for the simple reason i
did count 91 but then i noticed
in the pages themselves that there were
duplicates
so i didn't actually
count the clean pages so i don't know if
it's 51 77 or 91. the total that i went
through was 91
but there's duplicates in there
okay
now
did you review any uh discovery that was
provided by the prosecutors yes it went
over the police reports morris county
department's reports
the hospital reports
the emt reports the emergency room
reports the orthopedic reports
did you review any uh social media oh
yes
um this was rough because they were like
six boxes of facebook uh post like over
twenty thousand i looked i went through
a number of them
but um
i didn't record all that i went through
on my list but
there's one
box
for
mr goodwin i think it's
2000 or so
items
i also went over
text messaging back and forth between
different parties
now
with regards to the uh social media
posts did you talk to michael barrasson
about
various posts that he saw
um that lauren cataract posted
about him yes
and and
did you discuss any posts where she
talked about uh going to war yes
and and
what if any impact
did
those posts have on michael barrasso
well he's calm right now but when i was
talking with him he was like petrified
he was frightened
when he read and i read it i read him
the post to see what he was what it was
like you know how he reacted he was
frightened
um did you go over uh a post where
cataract talked about uh
weapons guns yes i also saw pictures she
had
of uh and what specific
effect
did that have on michael barrasso he was
super frightened he remained super
frightened
on one of the times that i was there
when i was leaving he said to me that um
he wanted to judge if he was freed
objection judge
don't say anything about
the church i'll move on
okay questions with drawn
in the discovery that she reviewed um
did you discuss
the fact that lauren cataract was tape
recording michael barrasso yes and did
you discuss
what impact
that recording was having on his mental
state
he was incredibly frightened
he had no refuse no place to go where he
felt safe
and uh he was very upset he said uh this
is an example of a terrorist you know
and
he was uh frightened
you know tremendous amount
and it upset him
that um
she had a post that
she referred to him and the other people
there scurrying around
going into their car
you know to
to speak to each other but he was just
very framed
what impact does
someone thinking whether it's true or
not
that every word that you say
is being listened to
judge i'm going to object to the general
nature of the question
yeah i think it's a little boring
rephrase it please
um
what effect is
michael barras don't think
thinking that every word that he spoke
to anyone
was being recorded by someone that he
was afraid of
it made him super paranoid
super paranoid
that everything he was doing was being
monitored not only being recorded he
thought that he was being filmed
did you revoke review posts with him
where
um lauren canorack was telling people on
facebook of facebook that michael
barisson was
threatening her life
that super
super frightened him super because he
has distorted thinking so here's what
his thinking was like
he said to me that um
the parkland shooting person
stated that he was bullied
then he said
kanarak said
she's bullied
so then he said my conclusion is she's
going to kill me
just like the parkland shooter
he that's how he his deduction
was off but that's what he
how we came up with that
and
did you discuss with him
numerous contacts that he made with
people
who cataract had previously
uh
posted things on facebook about yes uh
for instance the name staggered and
parkinson i remember that
now
i don't want you to say
what those posts contained
but you did did you discuss those posts
with michael barrasson yes
and
what did he say about those posts and
what was
their effect on his mental state well
the effect was it made him even more uh
frightened
he saw how
other people were treated
and he thought that there was a greater
danger
and he actually admitted that to me so i
asked him about like you know
how
things transpired to cause him all this
difficulty and he says well it was
the pattern of everything that came his
way
he looked up if he got information on
cataract her behavior and everything
together made him
more more frightened
but he felt as if there was a realistic
threat out there
now
did you discuss with him him leaving his
residence a week or so before
the
um the incident yes
and
what did he indicate to you was the
reason that he left
he feared for his
life who lucy living there with
with mary haskins
and uh i think for a time her son
and where did he uh go after he fled his
residence he went to the um
record i don't know if it's the proper
term the recreation room at the stable
it was a large room that was furnished
um that had a kitchen area there and
place to sleep
and he moved in
there now a reception area that's what
it was called
did
did michael barrasson uh based on your
discussions with him
and the discovery that he reviewed
take any steps to try to protect himself
he was frightened he he felt as if uh
uh
when he'd be talking to either mary
haskins or someone else
um that
canorac was quoting directly
what he was saying
and uh
he got more scared you know
and what he did was he hired someone to
sweep
the barn area
and to see if they could find any of the
tape recorders
i'm going to show you d700-2
did you review this in your uh
discovery yes i did
what is that
this is a contract for debugging it's i
think uh five thousand dollars
and um
of the
a certain area of the farm
did michael barzone hire anyone else
well he hired
a person to um
watch overnight
and to sit in his suv
and why did you hire that person because
she was fearful
because uh he was saying that uh lauren
cantarak and rob goodwin they'd be
wandering around at night
in the middle of the night and it was
fearful that they were going to do
something
do what
burn the barn down harm people
and uh he when he stayed at the
reception area he made sure that all the
windows and doors were locked
did he do any other anything anything
else to protect himself
um
did he hire a private oh yes yes yes he
hired a private investigator to find out
if they had a prior arrest record and
that upset him too
because he saw we
cannot go okay specifics but
700 8-1
is this the
background check
that you talked to michael barisson
about yes
and
can you tell the jury
what impact
michael barissone getting this document
from the private investigator had on his
mental state
it intensified the fear the fear factor
he felt as if
there was a whole bunch of information
that was pointing the direction that
these are dangerous people
did michael barrasson ever call the
police yes you did
approximately how many times
approximately four times
and
did you discuss those specific instances
with them yes i did
and what did he indicate to you with
regards to each and every one of those
instances total
frustration uh he was trying to say how
scared he was
he felt as if they were poo pooing it
and he had no place to turn that's how
he felt he had no recourse
and what did that do to his
he felt alone he felt vulnerable if you
know he felt as if
he felt as if he couldn't fight back so
to speak
at some point was he told that the
morris county prosecutor's office
was
consulted yes
and
did anything happen with regards to them
consulting about this incident based on
your review of the discovery
the the ap reviewed
the information that uh michael found
upsetting
and they didn't find it of sufficient uh
type to uh
follow through with any kind of action
it basically told him
that it was a landlord-tenant difficulty
and when michael barrisson heard that
both from the police and the
prosecutor's office
what effect did it have on him
felt more vulnerable he had no
protection
now
did michael barrasson talk to you about
uh um
his knowledge
of goodwin and canarax drug
use yes
i'm not gonna ask you specifics
but did that play any role in michael
barrissone's mental state with regards
to
your evaluation yes he felt both how so
he felt both of them
were unstable to begin with and he
thought with the drug use that they even
before even more unstable
and then
if i recall correctly he spoke to
someone who thought that drugs might be
planted on his vehicle and he got even
more scared
and
in addition to that information
did you talk to michael barissone about
warren cataract
posting things on social media
indicating that she had
mental
or psychological problems yes
did you discuss that with michael i did
and what impact did that have on his
mental state everything was drip drip
drip of making him more frightened
and um he particularly was frightened
when she essentially said that she had
multiple personalities and she could not
be responsible then he combined that
with images he saw of her where there
were gun images
statements that she made about shooting
at people who tried to um
objection just okay
all right sustained mr velenkus as
previously discussed
no did michael barriston talk to you
about an incident where
robert goodwin made uh some gesture with
his uh finger
yes
what specifically did he tell you about
that he said on august 6th
when the people from washington township
came to his place it was like three
different people
a number of cars
that came up he said rob goodwin was 15
feet away and he placed his hand in the
form of a gun
to his head
and uh said more to the effect uh watch
out or something like that
and he smiled on his face
and um
what did michael barriston say about
that smile to you he said it scared him
because she remembered um
something that happened long long time
ago when he was a little boy
he was sexually assaulted by someone he
says oh i saw the same kind of eyes the
frightening eyes they scared him the
same thing when he had trouble with his
mother when she burnt his hand
it was the same kind of eyes
and he it made him frightened he was it
was just fearful of them
now uh did you review the
uh police reports with regards to the
day of the incident yes
and and did you re view the reports
regarding
dcpp's contact with mary haskins and and
michael barrison yes
now what did michael barrasson tell you
with regards to
what he heard
during that meeting with bcpp the only
thing i thought he said
that he heard the word of sexual abuse
and that he was worried that the
family would be broken up the children
taken away
and um
he had a distorted view
that if the children were taken if he
and mary haskins were arrested his
biggest fear which is this is completely
delusional his biggest fear
i think is delusional his biggest fear
was that um
lauren kanarak and rob goodwin
would kill the children
and he linked it up with seeing some
posts
where they were
trying to get information on the two
children
but he was frightened judge objection
there's no evidence of that
let's see and sign more
in about 15 minutes you can step down
doctor okay
[Music]
i be seated members of the jury
the objection by
mr shellhorn was sustained in the last
testimony by
the doctor will be stricken from the
record and you're not to consider it
and the specific testimony is
where the doctor said his his previous
testimony where he talked about
mr barrissone's biggest fear
which was completely delusional in his
opinion was that the children would be
taken and killed by lauren canorack
and robert goodwin
that much you can consider but his
follow-up line that it was linked to a
specific post there's no evidence in the
record of that
that the defender never reviewed any
such post according to the doctor's
testimony so that last part must be
stricken you are not to consider it in
your deliberations
all right
let's bring the doctor in
now go ahead mr balance continue thank
you
doctor based on your clinical interviews
the psychological testing
and the information that you reviewed in
the record
uh did you form an opinion
with regards to michael barrasson's
state of mind at the time of the
incident yes i did
and is that opinion as to a degree of
psychological medical certainty yes it
is what is your opinion with regards to
michael barrasson's state of mind
at the time of this incident
at the time of the shooting
he suffered from a mental disorder
a psychotic break a delusional disorder
which degraded his thinking to such an
extent that he did not know what he was
doing was wrong
did he understand the nature and quality
of his actions no
nothing
all right cross examination
thank you judge
doctor good afternoon good afternoon
you're not board certified are you
they don't have board certification and
for psychologists it's for psychiatrists
have you ever had any problems with your
license no
now your cv indicates that you had
weekly meetings with uh dr james wallach
yes 2010. yes
he's a lawyer and a clinical
psychologist yes
what was the nature of your meetings
with him i would go over cases and i
wanted him to
serve as an attorney to question me
hard
in terms of what we were talking about
so i get more practice
why did you start meeting with him on a
weekly basis in 2000 i wanted to improve
i've done that over the years with
different people
i uh
contacted an expert in
the mmpi dr cornwall
and i met with him weekly and other
individuals that did the same so what i
tried to do in terms of my career i try
to find someone who is more
knowledgeable better than me and so to
speak i like to play tennis with them to
help
your cv indicates uh that you were
a post-doctoral fellow in
neuropsychology at columbia university
yes
and that's normally a two-year full-time
program it is
and you
did the fellowship for your fellow for
nine months i i yes i love the program
had you ever published any peer-reviewed
science published in any peer-reviewed
scientific journals
uh i don't know if it's peer-reviewed
but i wrote an article with arnold
lazarus on multimodal therapy
that was the article from 1990 yes
what's multimodal therapy it's a form of
cognitive behavior therapy
uh it was developed by arnold lazarus he
was a eminent uh psychologist at rutgers
university
and it basically
it um
tries to have interventions
with multiple components to it not just
one component but it looks at the broad
kind of player possibilities of
interventions for a person and that's
based or excuse me that's related to
therapy it's not related to
diagnostic uh
no it's therapy
now you were the chief operating officer
for the publishing company that puts put
that
book out one book there was a book that
was written by dr fay
prescription for quality relationship
and i developed a friendship with him
and through him i met uh
dr lazarus
now you're a member of the american
psychological association yes are you a
fellow
no
do you know what the criteria is to be
elected a fellow i don't know
would you be surprised if i told you it
was based on contributions
he's a member of the association judge
he said he didn't he said he didn't said
he didn't know
i'll move on have you ever held any
offices with any professional
associations no
have you ever received any awards from
any professional associations
no i just received the reward from the
prosecutor's office in hudson county on
a particular case that i did
so with respect to your peers uh in
these professional organizations you've
never received any awards no
now you indicated that you've testified
at trial in the past yes
have you testified for both the
prosecution and the defense yes can you
estimate approximately how many times in
the last
10 years you've done that i don't know
offhand um
but over the um
since my career at least 100 times
for each side
no not no enough for each side let's say
50 50.
have you ever been hired by the
prosecutor or the defense and then given
an opinion
that's inconsistent with the party
that's hiring you oh yeah
can you estimate approximately how many
times you've done that in the last time
can't do that but
i did that with deifis
and i did that with the parental
representation unit
now i saw on your cv that you listed an
update you attended at harvard medical
school in october of 2018. yes
how many days was that
it must have been four days
why do you say it must have been it
usually runs from like wednesday to
sunday
so it would be all day wednesday
thursday friday saturday and half a day
on sunday
and you know how many hours that would
be when you say days
jay
uh i don't know eight hours a day i'm
not sure
how would that
particular uh update be different from
the continuing education seminars that
were listed on page three
well the ones that are listed on page
three for continuing education were just
within forensic psychology
the the other ones that are listed
was on basically
dementia neuropsychology and psychiatric
issues
so that's how i differentiated it
have you ever given any seminars or
presentations to your peers in the field
of psychology well i i gave uh two
presentations to um the fellows at
columbia on forensic psychology
so i testified in the case of the
psychiatrist who was dr simmering he was
the director we were on opposite sides
in that particular case and after i
wrote my report he contacted me and
asked me if i would present to the
fellows so i presented for two years
and that was in 2008 and 2009
you've never presented that into the
national seminars or anything like that
no i had no interest
now you indicated that you gave a
battery of psychological tests to
michael barrison yes you would agree
with me that you would never make a
diagnosis based on a psychological test
correct
now you rendered a number of
psychological diagnoses for mr pearson
yes
would you agree with me that only
delusional disorder would affect his
ability to know and appreciate the
nature and quality of his actions yes
however
um
for the intentional problem that
contributes to why he has the delusional
disorder magnifies
it on its own it wouldn't affect his
ability participates in the forming
of
importing causing the impact
of the
delusions
doctor would you agree with me that two
people can have the same experience but
perceive it differently totally
and would you agree with me that someone
being mistaken about something is not a
delusion
no
it's not
it's not a delusion a delusion is an
experience that a person has
that is um
put together in their mind incorrectly
and i gave the example of like a
delusion like for example
michael barason saw
a facebook post
and on the facebook post
there was an orange color
the orange color generated in his mind
the idea of flames fire from that he
generated in his mind the notion
that uh his place was going to be burned
down
okay
so
i could look at it and someone else
could look at it and look at it
differently but the way he's thinking
about it is disturbed
well that wasn't my question my question
was if someone has a mistake about a
fact or they're mistaken about a fact
does that mean delusional no if i if i
said to you
that columbus
came to
the new world in 1592
i would be wrong
you know and that's not a delusion
that's just a statement of fact
would you agree with me that
a feeling
is not the same as a delusion
correct a delusion is a thought
it generates feelings
now i'm going to ask you some questions
about what you reviewed and what you
didn't review in the case uh but would
you agree with me in general that if
there was something that you didn't know
or something that you didn't account for
that you found out was different later
on that could change your opinion it
would influence it it depends on what it
is
i think you indicated that you had
reviewed a great deal of the discovery
in the case
did you review any of the witnesses
reported statements yes it did
and you indicated that you reviewed
the defendant's written statement that
he prepared for dr simran yes
and you said where you you said in your
report that that was only 51 pages that
it should be 91 pages yeah it's 91 pages
that what when i saw however i thought
within that there were duplicate pages
i can show you
all of those pages if you'd like to go
through them uh
to check whether there are duplicates or
are not duplicates
um i can't i would not want to do that
now but i would love to meet with you
because i
clearly remember reading it and i was
remarked this is
so very repetitious
did you corroborate anything that you
read there with any of the other
discovery
um
would you have to be more specific on
that i'm sorry
if you saw something or read something
there that was
and look i have to say this
i don't trust anything that a person
says to me
so i
you know they could claim one thing or
another and i tried to see if there's
an agreement so he would tell me all
kinds of things negative about let's say
lauren canorac and when i looked it up
it
that was coherent
with what he said the event took place
and you mentioned earlier that you spoke
with dr pacone
but then you indicated you corrected
yourself that was a typo in your report
yes
are you uh aware that she's not a doctor
uh i thought she was a doctor a
psychologist
and your notes actually indicate your
handwritten notes indicate phd next to
her name yes i mean where did you get
that from i thought that's what she said
phd
so you believe when you spoke to ms
picone
i thought she was a psychologist that
she told you she had a phd maybe she
didn't tell me but i thought she was a
psychologist i thought she was a doctor
now mr uh belingus asked you some
questions on direct examination about
the discrepancies between
your notes and your report and when you
actually met with michael barrett's own
versus william
yes and i wrote down on direct
examination that you
i'm going to said and see if my notes
are correct all right well he's
refreshing his recollection i suppose
but you don't have to you don't have to
reference what you wrote down well doc
just ask the question
did you meet with michael barissone on
october 29th
november 5th november 6th november 19th
november 20th
december 4th and december 5th
no i said i thought i said december 11th
well that's why i'm asking a question
fourth and the eleventh
[Music]
and you acknowledge that that's wrong in
your report
no i acknowledge the fact that the dates
i just gave you just read to me that's
the correct time
that was the correct dates that i saw
him
but that's not what it indicates
as far as the contacts and the the bill
that you gave correct correct
now i'm going to ask you some questions
about the various tests that you
uh administered doctor you talked about
the rorschach test yes
and you didn't actually administer the
rorschach
um
doctor you were asked questions on
direct about the rorschach test
yes
you scored
michael barrasson on the rorschach
using the
using nextner correct yes that's the
exeter system yes
sure
now there are a number of different
scoring systems for the workshop test
correct yes
and
you use the exener sort scoring system
when you did the score yes are you aware
of the rorschach research council
um
yes you're aware that that was a council
that was formed by john xner himself
in the mid 1990s okay yes
and are you aware that that council
identified a number of significant
problems with the egzner scoring system
yes
for example they noted that there's
issues with reliability between
different scorers
that's with all the rorschach systems
they indicated that the egzner system
was of questionable questionable
validity
questionable norms
they also indicated that there was no
research data that supported the x-men
scoring system i doubt that
let me show you if i can
uh s-409
for identification
uh in a breakout room please judge if i
could sure
it'll appear on that computer screen so
once it's pulled up
doctor can you see that screen okay
that's an article from psychological
science correct
okay
and does that indicate or refresh your
memory on the first page in that
italic type on the left hand side
the article was written by james wood
and i like his work i have his book on
the rorschach
uh he's very critical of the use of the
rorschach completely
now
the rorschach is very controversial test
there's two systems that exist right now
one by um
exner exonere system and one by meyer
there'd be very few people that would
agree with you to throw the baby out
with the bath and while i uh i tend to
support james woods analysis of the
rorschach i think you're going overboard
by saying that the system is recording
in progress
i think you're going overboard by trying
to imply
that the system is
negated by people in the psychological
community in a psychological community
um
so you don't agree that the exeter
system has a tendency to find illness
that is impressive
that's that's a common knowledge on the
rorschach system it's a common knowledge
right but that's not the full story
it's just not and doctor i'm just asking
you if you could answer my questions so
do you or do you not agree
that the exner system has a tendency to
find an illness that isn't present
that's one one point of view on that
that's one point of view
that's not the full
panoply of um
views on that
did you just uh who was the
individual that you just referenced
doctor james wood
i'm going to show you uh what's been
marked as s410
doctor is that an article from the
journal of personality assessment
yes and that was uh among the other
authors listed there are gregory meyer
yeah i know him
i know of him cited gregory meyer in
your report
yes
he has
another system that's been developed and
he's actually a member of the rorschach
research council yes
if
may i say something to you and he
actually
developed this additional
or different test the rpac yeah it's a a
rorschach system that's different
a lot of these things you're touching on
are very controversial
so if you get the book on the roshack
system by
wood at all
you'll see that
they imply
i'm not saying this is the case but they
imply that meyer was bought out
basically
by exner he had writ uh written
initially like in a dissertation a
criticism of the exynos system excellent
then placed him on board with regards to
um
the um
his group he was working with and he
changed his opinion that's that's the
implication in that book on the
rorschach
it's with gary lillian fell l-i-l-l-i
e-f-e-l-d
gary lillian fell wood and others
so
you're heading in into a very
controversial area
expert the exorcism is controversial
all the systems are controversial
i think i even referenced that within my
a report
you know saying that
there's questionable validity on some of
these systems i still think you could
use it so i also referenced a book
which is a legitimate book on assessment
of psychosis
did you testify today about the
potential issues or the validity issues
not at all because
that's not the summon substance of my
report
what i was doing is
i was taking the information from the
action that came out or the the
rorschach that was scored and it fits in
with other information
it
it's supported by other information
now do you have to pay any fees to use
that exner computer program
all the tests that i did i had to pay
for
so they're approximately forty dollars a
test maybe a little bit more do you have
to update that program periodically at
all
uh it depends on which company you're
using but like basically um
you pay per test
and you have to like for the
test from the psyc corporation
you buy a
access for a hundred dollars you buy an
access for doing the test and then you
pay per test
so it's enough for free
who runs uh the exeter system now or the
comprehensive system now that uh john xn
he passed away i don't know who's in
charge of it what happened was the
family initially said that they didn't
want any additional research but they
changed their opinion on that
are you aware that it's run by his
daughter
it could be
did you know that she's not a
psychologist or a psychiatrist to me
um i'm be honest i think you're heading
down a bad road because it's not a
doctor
doctor we're not here to argue i
apologize
mr doctor
both of you be quiet
your role here
is not to opine on any road the
prosecutor may be going down
that's his
decision your job is to answer the
questions that's it to the best of your
ability
now we got that out of the way ask
another question mr shelton
doctor i'm going to ask you about these
scores that you uh produced for the
rorschach test in this case
do you remember the interpretive report
that you got after rescoring the uh the
rorschach
i don't have it in front of me but
i remembered like key elements of it
specifically
did you list what you considered to be
the salient findings in your report yes
what's silly i mean
key findings
on page seven well i'll show it to you
doctor uh s 435
for identification
do you have that doctor yes and you
would agree with me that that's the
interpretive report for the scores you
gave michael barisson on the rorschach
i guess yes yes
if i direct your attention down to page
seven
specifically under number two
which is about halfway down the page
would you agree with me
that
it indicates there
that the individual
has a potential for impulsiveness
yes
you didn't include that in your report
did you
i don't know what i wrote on that i
thought that i wrote that he was
emotionally unstable
and i can direct your attention doctor i
see you looking at your report to pages
eight and nine
okay
so you'd agree with me that the
rorschach scoring that you did
indicated
uh and reflected a potential for
impulsiveness but you didn't include
that in your report yes
moving down on s435 which is the
rorschach uh on page eight
going to direct your attention to number
seven
that is does it indicate there
this individual exerts less considerably
less control over feelings than most
adults yes
does it indicate does not necessarily
signify that he is unable to exert
self-control and keep his emotions in
check but that he chooses not to do so
okay
you agree with me that's from the
results that you got
from the from that computer printout
and you didn't include that in your
report no
drawing your attention down to page 12
doctor
specifically number 21.
does it indicate
the individual is
excessively committed to seeing the
world accurately
yes and realistically
okay
and you would agree with me you didn't
put that in your report
no i don't need to on that
because for the simple reason that if an
individual has a delusional disorder i
did indicate
from another reference that it's not
going to be picked up
by
this test i had a long quote
so here's the thing
if you want to
pick pieces out of this report and say
it doesn't fit in
with
everything i've written the point is is
that i'm looking for things that overlap
that agree with each other
so
that's a factor that i use in terms of
generating a report
but there's no way that you could write
a report and think that you can put
every single piece together you have to
use some kind of clinical judgment
well you'd agree with me that if there
was
a common thread here of any of the
things we've talked about with these
other reports
and other tests rather and you didn't
put it in your report
but that
means that you ignored it i didn't
ignore it i didn't ignore it
i also just said to you previously
that i gave a quote from a current book
on the assessment of psychosis
and it said that you're not going to be
able to pick up
delusional disorder on the russia
and if you're trying to imply that just
because he has
a clear view of reality that doesn't
necessarily follow
you also didn't put any of these quotes
in your report or these uh passages in
your report and then distinguish them or
differentiate them did you
i didn't i don't believe i quoted i
thought i summarized
what i saw was in the reports
we just pointed out a number of things
that you didn't put in your report
correct you'll find that with every all
the testing that's done
and lastly on page 12 of 13 number 24.
you indicated earlier
in your testimony on direct examination
that the defendant was incapable of
understanding the nature and quality of
his actions yes
does page 12 indicate the individual is
capable of maintaining a connected flow
of associations in which ideas follow
each other in a comprehensible manner
okay but you also recall from yeah it
says that but you also recall
from a report that said it was a very
low number of responses
that
were produced
i also wrote in my report
the least number of responses you have
to have 14 responses
if you have less than 14 responses you
don't have a valid profile
and the fuel the responses are and it's
discussed by wood
and his associates
you can push down the pathology i
mentioned that in my report
so
you need to take that into account that
you could have a suppressed
level of pathology in it given the fact
that the number of responses were very
low
and i think my question was just that
that was a
indication that you received from the
tests and from the scores but that you
didn't include that in your report but i
just said that
you could read this
but if you also know how many responses
are given in the score and i have a
section here
that you can have a spuriously low
sign of pathology in the report given
you have very few responses
all right doctor let's move on to the
mmpi
the mmpi2
did you rescore this test
i ran it through the computer
now i think you testified on direct
examination
about the mmpi two correct
yes
and you testified in particular with
respect to scale six can you remember or
can you remind the jury what skill six
scale six measures paranoia
and it's fair to say that none of these
scale titles the names shouldn't be
interpreted literally no you should look
further into the test you should look at
the subcomponent scores
pa1 pa2 pa3 pa1
shows delusional thought content
of a very serious nature and doctor i'm
just asking you about scale six yes so
scale six is titled paranoia yes but it
doesn't literally mean that it's testing
paranoia
well it's just said literally that you
have to look at other scales on there
if you literally look at
other experts in the field
they're going to say it measures
delusional disorder
a score of 90.
so the high score of 90 on scale six
you would say is indicative of someone
with delusional disorder
yes
and not just simply on that and also and
doctor all right
please don't get ahead of me i
appreciate it thank you
well isn't it true that people with high
scores on scale six
rarely
endorse the existence of delusions
i don't believe that at all i've never
seen that
who is uh james butcher
oh i know james butcher he's one of the
mmpi uh
figures
and i think you cited him in your report
as well correct i might have
he's a reputable
person in with respect to the mnpi too
uh have you ever looked at his book
using the mnpi 2 in forensic assessment
no
judge if i may approach i don't have
this marked as an exhibit
well what's the next exhibit number just
so we have a reference
i believe it's s
454
s454
was that turned over to us
do you have an objection mr bolenkos
come to cyborg
54.
you would agree with me that this block
in the middle talks about scale six
paranoia let me read it
here's the problem you have with us
every t-score is here and doctor
you'll have a chance okay
but you'd agree with me
that this does say
with respect to scale six paranoia
the existence of delusions and paranoid
thought process are rarely identified
within this within this score
i agree that it says that there but i
also agree the fact that it doesn't have
the score of 90 in there
and that's a very different uh course of
another color
but you indicated you're you're familiar
with james butcher yes
now people who score uh high on scale
six are also generally described as
being suspicious
overly sensitive argumentative
prone to blame others yes
people with high scores on scale six
also often express their hostility
overtly and rationalize it as a result
of what others have done it's yes yes
and you indicated this defendant michael
barisson scored
high on scale six exchangingly high i
indicated that a t score of 90
i've never seen
in my career an individual score that
high
on scale six
with oblivious scales that within normal
limits
and the reference you're giving doesn't
give very high score it doesn't give any
scores it just gives a general
discussion
but you agree with me that james butcher
and others wrote in that report
that an individual
who scores high on the scale for
paranoia
rarely endorses the existence of
delusions it's incredibly misleading you
would agree with me that on the
references i'll ask the questions
respectfully
just answer the questions please so you
agree that you just read that in that
book yes i read that
now you indicated that some of the tests
that you administered the defendant
showed difficulty with his concentration
on some of the tests yes
on the mmpi 2
which is s434
for identification and we're going to
pull that up for you now doctor
uh
did michael barrasson endorse a number
of persecutory ideas
yes
and you'd expect that of a criminal
defendant who's on trial
not necessarily
i would expect that
someone who has a delusional disorder to
get a score of 90
on skill six and a score of 105 on scale
pa1
and also to get a score of
on the
uh caldwell index well if he indicates
in in respect to question 99 someone has
it in for me and says it's true yes
you would expect that for someone who's
been charged with a crime i i no i i
just think you're
i i just don't agree with you
[Music]
now with respect to the mcmi four
yes i don't know if you uh specifically
mentioned that on direct examination
well i administered it
however
i tried to check out the cut scores by
looking up rogers and i didn't use it
even though the test came out
in the same direction as the other tests
because the um validity scales were weak
on that
why did you use the mcmi4
it's a legitimate test i wanted to look
at personality disorder in him
however
i want to look at the current cut scores
so i looked up rogers and
he didn't have any information on that
and then i decided not to use it given
the fact that i wasn't sure if it was
valid the conclusions
doctor you mentioned the pai test on
your direct examination do you recall
that yes
and specifically with the pai
i think you testified
that you did validity testing with
respect to that test
is validity testing on there
judge this has been marked as s436
fought
doctor directing your attention to page
two
at the very top of the every page on
this document does it indicate warning
validity scales indicate hypotheses may
not be valid certainly does
and this test itself actually indicated
that there was
the possibility of deliberate distortion
i also indicated in my report
that i used richard rogers cut scores
for nim and
l
they're different from the scores on
this test
the cut scores for rogers the nim
negative
impression management has to be above
110 and the mal which is like an index
score of a group of different scores has
to be above five the mal that was
calculated was three
and the uh nim that was calculated was
92
so as i just said i went with rogers
with regards to this and i looked for
rogers with regard to the mcmi and i
didn't see anything so i didn't score
the mcmi
but that's why there's a discrepancy
so with respect to the pai
it does indicate that there's some
the possibility of some deliberate
distortion
with respect
to
the
one of the key experts in the united
states
i don't know anyone who's more renown
than richard rogers he's written
multiple uh
articles and books
on malingering and deception
that scores that are being shown here
are not invalid
did you indicate that in your report yes
you indicated that the pai
you wrote in your report that the pai
indicated quote the possibility of
malignant you wrote that in your report
i indicated in my report that i used the
cut scores from richard rogers for nim
and mal i indicated that
i didn't use the scores that were shown
here
well specifically i'll direct your
attention to page 10 of the pai that you
administered and you scored
does it indicate in the first full
paragraph
on page 10 the critical items should be
reviewed to evaluate the possibility of
malingering where is this now on on my
report
pai page 10.
it's been marked for identification as s
s436 and it should be on the screen in
front of you okay
yes
what is your question you see you see
there where this report
based on the test that you administered
and you scored
indicates the critical items should be
reviewed
to evaluate the possibility of
malingering i also just indicated you a
few times see that yes i would know i
see them
and in that same paragraph does it say
regardless of the cause in all capital
letters
the test results potentially involve
considerable distortion
and are unlikely to be an accurate
reflection of the respondent's objective
clinical
the following status
is provided only as an indication
of the respondent's self description
you agree with me that the pai that you
administered and scored gave you that
indication
i agree with
what you just read there but i also
agree with myself
that richard rogers who's a higher
authority
than the computer printout
would argue that those scores were not
they were genuine they were not uh an
indication of feigning
and i gave you the score is that in your
report it's in my report it says that
the idea is that the critical items
should be reviewed for the possibility
of malingering now what it says in my
report is that i use richard rogers
cut scores for it
well here's what rogers did
doctor okay please just answer my
questions
i will thank you
now the pai also gave a number of
diagnostic possibilities didn't it yes
did it indicate the diagnostic
possibility of delusional disorder
no
did it indicate that malingering should
be ruled out
it could be given the fact that using
the incorrect cut scores on here
well let me draw your attention and this
is a score this is a test you chose
correct
i you chose to administer the pai to the
defendant let me let me make a comment
to you doctor could you please just
trust her i use this test right but i
have to use my judgment too i have more
knowledge
that i try to use in terms of
understanding it
so i looked at
the cut scores by richard rogers he
takes into
richard rogers is trying to
reduce
false positives
so he and his group took this test they
wanted to
reduce false positives false positive
would be say someone is malingering when
they're not and actually malingering is
not a diagnosis as you probably know
you chose to administer
the pai to michael garrison correct yes
you took the results and you put them
into this particular program to score it
correct yes
the program
gave you a number of various
information
clinical features
treatment
considerations possible diagnosis
correct yes
and you didn't include
all of those things in your report i
would never encourage everything any
report i would use my judgment
on the report the test gave two things
the equality scales
and also gave clinical scales the
validity scale said
that the test was accurate
and where the results of the pai that
you have in front of you as s46
didn't match your ultimate diagnosis
you didn't put anything your in your
report about why you ignored that
or why you distinguished it
i indicated
that i'm not putting down my lingering
given the fact that there's no evidence
of fainting on this test
because i used more accurate cut scores
so where it says
there's the possibility of malingering
you're saying that feigning is not
indicated at all by this test
correct
doctor you also uh mentioned that you
administered the 16
pf fest yes
i know you mentioned several of the
factors
i don't think you mentioned factor l
what does factor l measure vigilance
high suspiciousness
did michael barason have an extremely
high score on this scale yes
his scale or his score rather for this
scale was at the top of the range yes
and a score
like that
would suggest problems with the
projection of anger correct
it would suggest a preoccupation with
power dynamics
correct
you'd agree with me that's not indicated
in your report
well i interpret it differently than you
i didn't interpret it as power dynamics
i interpreted as hyper suspiciousness
doctor i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s 443
for identification
this is the 16 pf
results
from the test that you administered
you just indicated that you wouldn't say
that factor l
deals with the preoccupation of power
dynamics but you'd agree with me that
that's exactly what it says in the test
results it says it there
now you mentioned doctor that you gave
the sirs to correct yes
why did you pick the surge 2 as opposed
to the surge 1.
well the source 2
is a better test
in that it was developed to reduce
false
positives so in other words accusing
someone of either malingering or
feigning when they're not
it was an upgrade
well isn't it true that in the
scientific community that there are
concerns about whether this serves to
accurately assess his dating
i'm going to respond to you
that's a complete misstatement
now there were three
studies that came out
they criticized
the use of surge2
basically the problem
with those three studies
the design was poor
and what they used was
a test called the miller
forensic test the miller forensic test
is high on
sensitivity remember i gave the example
going through a magnetometer it goes off
the
sirs 2
is high on specificity
they used the wrong tests and the wrong
design
to criticize the
service too there was three of those
studies that was answered by rogers when
he went over the
designs of those studies
so if authors published an article
in a peer-reviewed
scientific journal
where they indicated that they had
concerns about whether the sirs 2
accurately measures whether someone's
fainting or not you would disagree with
those authors and disagree with that
scientific study i would agree with
rogers when he analyzed those studies
and found that they were flawed
those studies were seriously flawed
what they did was they used a screening
test
for uh malingering or feigning a
screening test and they compared it to
his test his test is not a screening
test his test is designed to
have heightened
specificity
not have false positives
the other test on the other side the
miller was set up for high sensitivity
to go off every time a person walked
through that magnetometer this test only
goes off if someone walks through the
magnetometer like with a gun in their
pocket
doctor let me ask you some questions
about the tom
is that an acronym for the test of
memory malingering yes
and you indicated that you gave that
test to michael barrisson yes one of
four tests
and you indicated that when you gave
michael barasone the test of memory
malingering that he had a four score
he had a score of 41. on trial 2 and 12
4.
and i think you indicated
that to the jury on direct examination
that
that score is poor it's on yes a score
um under 45 is considered
a problem
with the exception if someone has some
kind of like brain injury
a tbi or something of that sort and you
didn't note any issues like that with mr
barrisson well i did write
after i considered that
that he has some problem with
visual memory and there's some problem
with the tension and he also mentioned
that an odd finding was that on the vip
which is a a very certain that's the
a very superior test
on the
non-verbal part there was indication a
problem sustaining attention so i
hypothesized that there's a possibility
that the 41 score was due to the fact
of his difficulty in different areas
now you just testified that a score
under 45
is a problem
yes i think that was your exact words
and you indicated that michael barrasson
scored a 41 on the test of memory
malignant correct yes
that was on
two of the trials correct
trial two and the recognition trial
his score on trial one was a 35 yes
you didn't include that in your report
you don't that's not you not how you
analyze it
i didn't ask that question doctor you
never include that
well a score of 41
is actually indicative of someone who is
likely malingering correct
possibly so if they don't have any other
difficulty that's maybe impacting the
school
judge i'm going to ask
to show
the witness i have it on my computer but
because it was highlighted i think it's
difficult to read
so this has been marked as s422
and doctor i apologize that this is
difficult to read here
but would you agree with me that it says
any score lower than 45 on trial two
or on the retention trial should raise
concerns that the individual is not
putting forth maximum effort and is
likely malingering keep on reading
rather
i can't read that
i'm just i'm sorry doctor
rather than using the score of 45 as a
rigid cut
cut off it should be viewed as a
guideline yes with the likelihood of
malingering increasing as the score
deviates further from the normative
baseline
for each specific diagnostic group okay
you didn't indicate that in your report
did you
no what i indicated was he's got a score
of 41 and 41 and i indicated possible
reasons for the low score and it's
inconsistent with the
high scores on
the
vip
and you excluded the 35
i would never report 30 the first call
it's not part of the analysis
you give the first test and you give the
second and you give the retention
judge i don't anticipate that i'm going
to finish in the next 15 or 20 minutes i
can certainly keep going
um i want to keep going a little while
longer since we don't have um tomorrow
morning
so you can keep going just just for 10
minutes
you had been asked questions about
amnesia on direct examination yes
and you indicated that uh you diagnosed
the defendant with dissociative amnesia
yes localized
and i think you testified on direct
examination that it could be
dissociative amnesia yes
i chose to diagnose that when you were
asked whether you were sure of that or
certain made that uh opinion within a
reasonable degree of psychological
certainty is that the same as it could
have been
yes
more likely than not
do you agree with me that there's no
memory disorder that's selective just
for criminal behavior
i don't know what that means
was there anything
in the dsm
that would indicate someone could have a
memory disorder that's selective just
for the time that they're doing
something that's criminal it's possible
i wouldn't rule out any of that and i
wouldn't use the word malingering
because if you're going to use the word
lingering you have to show a test
that is positive for feigning
there's no test that i gave the joanie
feigning
so my question was
is there any diagnosis
in the dsm
that deals with someone's memory
being selected just for the time when
they commit a crime no
now you'd agree with me that the dsm
also indicates
that veined amnesia is found more
commonly in individuals with legal
problems
well i think the reference is not they
they say
they don't use feigned they use
malingering amnesia
right
as a v code the v code in that book
uh i think on page 715 or so it
basically states that in criminal
situations you should suspect
that there's malingering but it doesn't
prove that there's malingering in this
case because it's not just a simple
criminal act it's the fact that
he can't remember something that was
incredibly stressful
and my question was isn't it true that
famed amnesia is more commonly found in
individuals with legal problems
i don't know that
i don't know any data on that is it true
that feigned amnesia is more commonly
found in individuals who wish to escape
stressful situations
dissociative amnesia often comes with
people who are in stressful situations
but they don't call it
you're using a term that doesn't exist
you're saying feign amnesia
the term that's in there is dissociative
amnesia that's an emotional type of
amnesia
judge i'm going to refer to the dsm-5
again this hasn't been marked
all right
and i'll mark it when we're done with
port church
doctor you just said that feigned
amnesia isn't a term that's in the dsm
not that i know of with the diagnostic
number i'm going to direct your
attention to page
298 you would agree with me
okay that this page talks about
dissociative amnesia yes that's the
diagnosis that you came up with for
michael bearson
correct
you would agree with me that there are a
number of things listed after the
criteria diagnostic features correct
associated features risk and prognostic
factors yes
and if we get here to page 301
it says factitious disorder and
malendering correct correct and you'd
agree with me that the book
says feigned amnesia is more common in
individuals with
legal problems correct yes it also says
feigned amnesia is more common in
individuals with
a wish to escape stressful circumstances
okay
does it then go on many individuals who
malinger
confess spontaneously or when confronted
well
it's a strange article there
because there's no specific diagnosis
for famed amnesia it doesn't have a
number
there's no number doctor if you recall
my question it wasn't whether or not
there was a number or whether or not
there was a specific diagnosis i asked
you
if the diagnostic and statistical manual
indicates
that famed amnesia is more commonly
found in individuals with legal problems
possibly so
but that criteria that amnesia does not
appear in the dsm when you look at
malingered amnesia it's
wrong i could show you the data 80 of
the time now i'm not saying
that anyway
and doctor i'm just asking you about
your diagnosis yes you diagnosed the
defendant with
the sociability of the associated
dissociative amnesia localized
and you would agree with me that in the
comments or the follow-up statements
about dissociative amnesia it talks
about feigned amnesia
in that same paragraph they use the word
malingering and they use the word famed
those are two different concepts i don't
know if they made a mistake or what the
authors of
the american psychiatric association
made a mistake so they published the
csm5 so look on page 715 i believe at 7
15. for conditions v codes and on that
page
it discusses malingering
and those diagnoses malingering are
wrong 80 percent of the time
now you indicated
we just read rather
that it's true that individuals who
malinger
may confess spontaneously
okay
you would agree with me at least
that that's what we just read out of the
american
psychiatric association's dsm five okay
yes
you would agree that michael barrasson
was overheard
at the scene saying i had a good life
okay
you would agree that he was overheard in
the ambulance saying is this real and i
need to wake up yes
you'd agree that in the ambulance he
also said
someone drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids yes
you'd agree that the defendant was
overheard later at the hospital saying
they destroyed my life in the last six
months and they took it all away yes
did you ask him what he meant by any of
those statements yes
did he tell you that he doesn't know he
doesn't know what they meant he doesn't
even know how his arm was broken
and you believe the the timing and
substance of those specific statements
is vague
they're not vague but you have to have a
context
didn't you write in your report that
they were vague
well i i asked him what they meant i
didn't know what they meant
i don't know if
what he's referring to or those
statements are referring to
it's not clear to me do you recall in
the written statement that he wrote for
dr simran
where he indicated on a certain page
that after the
dcp worker got there and he was in his
office
that he only remembered two or three
things that were blurry at best
that's in his report
dr simran's report but i i didn't ask
that what he remembered
i asked him the last thing he remembered
the defendant saying he remembered two
or three things and it's blurry at best
is in dr simmering's report i believe i
believe it's in dr simran's report
but i or it's in um the the uh
51 the 91 pages but i didn't ask him on
that i asked him the last thing he
remembered so you didn't ask him what
the two to three things were that he
remembered after he was in his office
after what he said what he said he
remembered
was
a lightning bolt coursing through his
body feeling confused had trouble
breathing it was like he was having a
panic attack and he didn't know where he
was what he was doing
and the next thing he remembered was
waking up at the hospital
and then i said well what was the first
thing you what you recall when you were
waking up and he said to me i asked for
a priest and then i asked if my children
were safe
i had asked you the question earlier
doctor are you going through a different
area all right
we'll break now it's about uh 20 of we
want 10 minutes over i don't want to go
any further
you get the morning off ladies and
gentlemen
and we're going to resume at 1 30 or as
close to 130 as we can
so please be here about around one
o'clock or so 1 15 at the latest all
right thank you all please don't discuss
the case
you